[Musique]
la séance est reprise
notre ordre du jour appelle une
déclaration du gouvernement
suivie d'un débat en application de
l'article 50-1 de la Constitution
relative à la guerre en Ukraine et on
conséquence pour la France je rappelle
qu'après avoir donné la parole à madame
la Première ministre la parole sera
donnée aux orateurs des groupes 9 sont
inscrits puis
madame la mise de l'Europe des Affaires
étrangères
est mise armées pourront répondre au
débat je donne la parole à madame la
Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs
il y a 8 mois la Russie a attaqué
l'Ukraine
cette guerre est illégale contraire à
toutes les règles du droit international
cette guerre est destructrice elle
provoque chaque jour plus de dommages et
de victimes
cette guerre est cynique elle est le
fruit de mensonge et la Russie utilise
sans vergogne la manipulation et les
pires chantages
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ce
conflit touche d'abord un pays l'Ukraine
et son peuple
depuis 8 mois autour du président
Zelinski du Premier ministre schmial et
des forces armées les Ukrainiens
résistent aux assauts russes
mieux il les repousse
leur courage force l'admiration
leur héroïsme force le respect
malgré les morts malgré les drames le
peuple ukrainien se bat et n'a jamais
rien cédé
je veux commencer au nom du gouvernement
et j'en suis sûr en votre nom à tous par
dire notre soutien et notre solidarité
pleine et entière envers le peuple
ukrainien
mais nous le savons ce qui se joue dans
ce conflit dépasse largement les
frontières de l'Ukraine
le président de la République l'a dit ce
conflit engage notre responsabilité à
tous
en Ukraine ce sont nos valeurs qui sont
attaquées
Vladimir Poutine la reconnaît lui-même
en menant cette guerre c'est notre
modèle démocratique qui vise ce sont les
droits de l'homme qui veut faire
flancher alors nous devons montrer que
nos valeurs sont fortes et qu'on ne peut
pas s'en prendre sans conséquence à la
démocratie
cette guerre est un moment de vérité
l'ordre international est bouleversé
l'espoir d'une paix durable en Europe et
balayée certaines grandes puissances
montrent qu'elles sont prêtes à tout
pour s'imposer
face à cela nous avons un devoir de
solidarité
solidarité envers les Ukrainiens qui
risquent leur vie
solidarité entre Européens qui doivent
faire bloc face à la Russie et penser
leur avenir ensemble
solidarité entre alliés qui doivent agir
conjointement pour dissuader la Russie
d'aller plus loin
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ce
conflit durent et va durer
l'attaque russe a des conséquences très
concrètes pour notre pays pour nous
concitoyens des conséquences dont nous
n'avons malheureusement pas fini de
mesurer les effets
il était donc important de nous
retrouver et de débattre de ce conflit
et de ses conséquences pour notre pays
je souhaite commencer par un point sur
la situation opérationnelle
l'attaque russe a été synonyme d'un
déchaînement de violence en dépit de
toutes les règles
les civils les écoles les hôpitaux les
centres commerciaux et même les convois
humanitaires sont pris pour cible sans
discernement
les frappes Russes se poursuivent les
grandes villes et notamment Kiev sont
prises pour cible par des attaques de
drones ou des tirs de missiles de
croisière sur des zones résidentielles
l'objectif de ces tir n'est pas
militaire il est de détruire et de
terroriser
les Russes mènent par ailleurs une
attaque ciblée contre les
infrastructures énergétiques
ukrainiennes
les frappes sur la centrale du Sud
Ukraine et l'occupation militaire de la
centrale de zapporigia par les Russes
font courir des risques majeurs à
l'Ukraine à l'Europe et à la Russie
elle-même
la situation à zapporicien nous
préoccupe en particulier
nous soutenons la proposition du
directeur général de l'IEA d'établir une
zone de protection autour de la centrale
ce serait une étape vers la
démilitarisation la cessation complète
des tirs ainsi que le retrait des
équipements militaires russes les
discussions à cet effet doivent
évidemment respecter la souveraineté
ukrainienne et son intégrité
territoriale
mais depuis le 10 octobre c'est
l'ensemble du réseau électrique
ukrainien qui est en péril et un tiers
du parc énergétique ukrainien a déjà été
mis hors d'usage par l'armée russe
dans les territoires occupés on assiste
à des transferts de population forcées y
compris d'enfants
là où l'armée ukrainienne progresse la
libération s'accompagne de la découverte
de massacres et de charniers comme à
bout de chat au printemps et plus
récemment à isium
ce sont des actes choquants révoltants
monstrueux ce sont des violations
barbares des lois de la guerre la Russie
devra en répondre
nous sommes déterminés à ce que les
crimes commis par la Russie soient
documentés
et puni la France y contribue
au-delà du champ de bataille la Russie
mène une guerre sur tous les fronts je
pense aux cyberattaques je pense aux
manipulations de l'information
parmi les dernières manipulations de la
Russie je note les propos
invraisemblables du ministre de la
Défense russe sur l'utilisation d'une
bombe sale par l'Ukraine ce n'est rien
d'autre qu'un mensonge supplémentaire de
Moscou pour légitimer l'escalade
n'ayons aucun doute la Russie est prête
à aller plus loin Poutine n'hésite pas à
menacer d'utiliser toutes les armes à sa
disposition il continuera à le faire
mais malgré la violence et les méthodes
de la Russie l'Ukraine repousse
aujourd'hui la Saurus
dans les eblastes de Donetsk et de
luansk l'avancée russe a été arrêtée une
côte enfoncive a commencé avec des
résultats visibles l'armée
ukrainienne a réussi des percées dans
les régions de carquiv et de Liman et
progresse également dans le sud dans la
région de Kerson à date on compte 600
villages libérés par l'Ukraine
face à cela Vladimir Poutine a répondu
par de nouvelles décisions cyniques
c'est le cas de la mobilisation
partielle qu'il a décrété le 21
septembre une mobilisation qui a été
suivie de contestation et de départ
massif vers l'étranger
c'est aussi le cas de la mascarade des
référendums truqués dans la dans les
régions de l'est de l'Ukraine
Vladimir Poutine fait semblant de croire
qu'une parodie de démocratie pourrait
camoufler une annexion illégale
mais la France par la voie du président
de la République
l'Union européenne et l'Assemblée
générale des Nations Unies ont toute
condamné cette annexion illégale et ont
refusé de la reconnaître
malgré les fragilités russes nous
croyons pas un instant que la fin des
combats soit proche
la mobilisation russe apportera de
nouveaux soldats sur le front
l'arrivée de nouvelles troupes russes en
Biélorussie nous préoccupe
collectivement la Russie est prête à
tout et ce n'est pas sur un champ de
bataille mais autour d'une table de
négociation que nous trouverons une
issue à cette guerre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs en
attendant que les conditions d'une
sortie du conflit soit réunie nous avons
un devoir et des l'Ukraine autant que
nous pouvons sans rentrer en guerre avec
la Russie
dès le début du conflit en s'adressant
aux Français le président de la
République avait prévenu cette guerre
marquée une rupture nous n'avions pas
fini d'en mesurer les effets
pourtant nous n'avons pas hésité une
seconde à agir si nous n'avions pas agi
en européen en Allier en nation libre et
fidèle à ses valeurs nous aurions ouvert
la porte la porte a un ordre
international brutalisé ou la fin
justifie tous les moyens
nous aurions laissé penser que les
démocraties étaient faibles
nous aurions planté les germes de
conflits futurs qui nous auraient menacé
encore plus directement
alors depuis le début du conflit avec
l'Europe et avec les alliés nous avons
décidé de livrer du matériel militaire à
l'Ukraine
dès la fin du mois de février notre pays
a commencé les livraisons d'armements
nous avons d'abord livré des armes
individuelles des munitions et du
carburant
puis sont venus s'ajouter des
équipements plus lourds comme des canons
César et des véhicules blindés nous
poursuivons aujourd'hui nos efforts nous
allons livrer très prochainement des
systèmes anti-aériens comme le crotale
et nous étudions l'envoi de moyens
d'artillerie supplémentaires comme des
lance-roquettes unitaires
nous continuons également à agir en
européen
l'Union européenne à d'ores et d'ores et
déjà mobilisés 2,5 milliards d'euros au
titre de la facilité européenne de paix
pour apporter du matériel militaire à
l'Ukraine et les 27 viennent de décider
d'y ajouter 500 millions d'euros de plus
par ailleurs nous soutenons le lancement
d'une mission d'assistance militaire de
l'Union européenne qui va permettre de
dispenser des formations aux forces
armées ukrainiennes
l'objectif de cette mission est dans un
premier temps de former 15000 militaires
Ukrainiens la France en accueillera 2000
il fallait trouver un moyen de faciliter
l'acquisition par l'Ukraine de matériel
répondant au mieux à ses besoins le
président de la République a ainsi
annoncé au début du mois la mise en
place d'un fond spécial doté de 100
millions d'euros pour permettre à
l'Ukraine de commander des matériels
directement auprès de nos industriels ce
fond s'ajoute à la part française de
financement de la facilité européenne
pour la paix
les premières commandes ont déjà été
faites nos industriels doivent s'engager
fortement pour y répondre
au delà la France agit en alliée fiable
et crédible
dès les premiers jours du conflit à la
demande du Président de la République
nous avons renforcé notre dispositif sur
le flanc Est de l'OTAN la semaine
dernière nous avons annoncé un nouveau
renforcement de notre dispositif
militaire dans le cadre des missions de
réassurance de l'Alliance dans les
prochains jours nous allons projeter des
chars Leclerc en Roumanie où nous sommes
nation cadre de la mission de l'OTAN en
Lituanie des rafales seront déployés
avant la fin de l'année et pour quatre
mois
nos véhicules de combats d'infanterie
griffons les plus modernes iront en
Estonie
cette présence en Roumanie et dans les
États baltes illustrent l'engagement
avec nos alliés
la Russie pensait trouver le temps
faible et divisé elle a ressoudé
mais notre soutien militaire n'est
qu'une partie de notre action
dès les premiers jours de la guerre avec
l'Union européenne nous avons pris des
sanctions fortes
là encore Vladimir Poutine pensait
diviser l'Europe elle a fait face et
montrer son unité et sa détermination
face à la crise
je dirais même plus bien malgré lui le
président Poutine a renforcé l'Europe
le premier paquet de sanctions a été
adopté en moins de 24 heures et ce sont
en tout huit paquets qui ont été adoptés
jusqu'à présent
notre objectif est le même depuis le
début rendre le coup de la guerre
insupportable pour la Russie frapper
durement son économie pour l'empêcher de
financer son offensive
nous avons pris des sanctions massives
et de tous les ordres financières
bancaire commercial
des sanctions contre la propagande russe
et contre les dirigeants et les
oligarques avec les huitièmes paquet
adopté ce sont près de 1300 personnes
directement touchées par des gels
d'avoir ou des interdictions de voyage
en Europe
l'Europe n'a pas reculé devant les
décisions courageuses je pense notamment
à l'embargo sur les importations de
charbon de pétrole brut et de produire
raffinés russes
avec les prix élevés de l'énergie Moscou
préserve l'illusion mais les faits sont
là les sanctions fonctionnent l'économie
russe est entrée en récession et elle
sera durablement affectée par son
obstination Vladimir Poutine hypothèque
l'avenir de son pays et appauvrit son
propre peuple
nous sommes ferme nous n’hésitons pas
non plus à sanctionner ceux qui
soutiennent la guerre du président russe
vendredi dernier l'Union Européenne
ainsi sanctionné l'Iran qui a fourni des
drones à la Russie pour mener ses
exactions
abandonner les sanctions ce serait
abandonné du crâne ce serait aussi
trahir nos valeurs
je veux être très clair les sanctions
continueront tant que Vladimir Poutine
s'évertira dans sa spirale belliqueuse
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
notre soutien à l'Ukraine passe par les
livraisons de matériel par les sanctions
il s'incarne aussi dans une action
humanitaire résolue
en France plus de 200 millions d'euros
ont été mobilisés et 2500 tonnes de
matériels livrés
nous nous sommes organisés aussi pour
accueillir les Ukrainiens chassés par la
guerre plus de 100 000 ont été
accueillies et près de 19000 enfants ont
été scolarisés cela s'est fait
rapidement
efficacement dignement
nous avons pu agir grâce à l'action
rapide et exemplaire de l'Europe dès le
3 mars les 27 ont accordé la protection
temporaire au déplacées ukrainien c'est
une première et 4 millions de personnes
en bénéficient aujourd'hui à l'échelle
européenne
je sais également que notre action
humanitaire aurait été impossible sans
l'élan de se vider solidarité nationale
qui s'est engagée depuis 8 mois je pense
à nous ONG à nous entreprises je pense
bien sûr à nos compatriotes ce qui
accueille des déplacés Ukrainiens chez
eux recevront prochainement une aide je
pense aussi et je le dis tout
particulièrement devant le Sénat à nos
collectivités elles ont été mobilisées
engagées elles permettent l'accueil et
la scolarisation des déplacés Ukrainiens
elles sont indispensables face à cette
crise et avec vous je veux saluer leur
action
notre soutien à l'Ukraine est également
diplomatique
l'Ukraine fait pleinement partie de la
famille européenne lors du Conseil
européen en juin le statut de pays
candidat à l'Union européenne lui a été
accordé à l'unanimité
le chemin de l'adhésion est long
exigeant il n'y aura pas de procédure
accélérées ou de critères ou rabais ce
ne serait dans l'intérêt de personnes ni
de l'Union européenne ni de l'Ukraine
sans préjudice de ce processus
d'adhésion la communauté politique
européenne proposée par le Président de
la République se met en place elle
permettra à tous ces membres dont
l'Ukraine de bénéficier de coopération
concrète par exemple dans les domaines
de l'énergie des infrastructures ou de
la sécurité
la première réunion de la communauté
politique européenne le 6 octobre à
Prague a été un succès 44 chefs d'État
et de gouvernement ayant pris part et la
pertinence de ce format a été
unanimement saluée c'est une première
étape de très bonne augure pour la
deuxième réunion de cette nouvelle
communauté prévue en Moldavie le
semestre prochain
enfin soutenir l'Ukraine c'est
accompagné sa reconstruction
on évalue pour l'instant après de 350
milliards d'euros les besoins du pays
pour se reconstruire
c'est un défi colossal un défi d'autant
plus important que ce montant va sans
doute encore s'accroître
l'Ukraine ne réussira pas seul et nous
serons en français et en Europe 1 à ses
côtés
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
le savons tous les conséquences de la
guerre dépassent largement les
frontières de l'Ukraine
aussi depuis février le gouvernement
agit sans relâche pour limiter l'impact
du conflit sur notre pays
le premier défi est énergétique
la guerre et la raie quasi totale des
livraisons de gaz russe vers l'Europe
ont provoqué des tensions
d'approvisionnement et de nouvelles
hausses des prix
rappelons que c'est bien la Russie qui a
lancé cette guerre c'est elle qui nous
pousse à répondre en retour c'est encore
elle qui fait du gaz et de l'énergie un
objet de chantage
en outre tout indique que des actes de
sabotage grave et irresponsables ont été
commis contre les gazeux duc Nord Stream
1 et 2 une enquête internationale
indépendante est en cours il ne
m'appartient pas de tirer des
conclusions ici je venais en moins le
dire nous répondrons avec nos
partenaires de manière ferme et unie à
cette attaque contre les infrastructures
énergétiques européennes
dans ce contexte nous sommes prêts à
affronter les mois qui viennent
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le détailler
devant vous leur donnes de notre débat
sur la politique énergétique nous avons
anticipé la situation
et grâce à notre action préventive grâce
à la sobriété et à la solidarité
européenne
nous sommes mis en mesure de traverser
l'hiver sans coupure
nous travaillons aussi vous le savez
pour limiter l'impact de la montée des
prix sur le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens très tôt nous avons pris des
mesures fortes les plus protectrices
d'Europe le bouclier tarifaire a permis
de bloquer les prix du gaz et de limiter
la hausse des prix de l'électricité pour
les ménages les très petites entreprises
et les plus petites communes le mois
dernier j'ai annoncé que le bouclier
tarifaire serait prolongé les prix
auraient dû doubler la hausse sera
limitée à 15%
mais au-delà des ménages nous devons
protéger les entreprises et les
collectivités face à la hausse des prix
je sais que c'est un sujet sur lequel
vous êtes particulièrement mobilisés
nous voulons d'abord traiter le problème
à la racine en faisant baisser les prix
le président de la République est
pleinement investi pour trouver une
solution européenne le Conseil européen
des vins et 21 octobre a ouvert la voie
à plusieurs mesures d'abord pour faire
baisser les prix du gaz nous avons mis
en place des outils pour favoriser les
achats communs de gaz
nous travaillons aussi à un mécanisme
pour limiter la hausse du prix de
l'électricité nous défendons vous le
savez l'extension à toute l'Europe du
dispositif qui a permis de diviser par
deux voire trois les prix en Espagne
plus largement nous devons engager une
réforme structurelle du marché de
l'électricité pour que ces prix
reflètent mieux et durablement la
réalité des coûts de production en
parallèle nous travaillons pour protéger
des entreprises et des collectivités
face à la flambée des prix de l’énergie
le gouvernement présentera des mesures
en ce sens d'ici la fin de la semaine
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
au-delà des réponses d'urgence nous
devons tirer toutes les conséquences de
cette guerre et préparer l'avenir
ce conflit nous a rappelé l'importance
de notre souveraineté une souveraineté
française et européenne
c'est une souveraineté énergétique que
nous devons bâtir en accélérant notre
sortie des énergies fossiles
nous y parviendrons par une stratégie
ambitieuse autour de la sobriété du
nucléaire et des énergies renouvelables
hier soir et aujourd'hui vous avez
examiné en commission le projet de loi
pour favoriser le développement des
énergies renouvelables je suis convaincu
que nous pourrons trouver des points
d'accord et avancer sur ce texte
ensemble
ensuite nous devons bâtir notre
souveraineté alimentaire
dès le mois de mars des mesures ont été
prises avec l'appui de l'Union
européenne pour protéger les
agriculteurs et les consommateurs nous
agissons également en français et en
européen pour faciliter la cheminement
des exportations agricoles ukrainiennes
par ailleurs nous prendrons le chemin de
la souveraineté alimentaire grâce aux
investissements de France 2030 et la
future loi d'orientation et d'avenir
pour l'agriculture
enfin cette guerre nous prouve une fois
de plus l'urgence de consolider notre
souveraineté stratégique
au niveau national la guerre nous
conforte dans la décision de poursuivre
les efforts engagés dans le cadre de la
loi de programmation militaire actuelle
le président de la République a
réaffirmé son ambition
disposait d’armée au meilleur niveau
prête à agir et à prendre l'ascendant
dans tous les milieux
une analyse poussée a été menée dans le
cadre de la revue nationale stratégique
qui a fait l'objet d'échange avec les
commissions compétentes des deux
assemblées sur ce fondement une nouvelle
loi de programmation vous sera présentée
au premier semestre 2023
enfin cette guerre a prouvé une fois de
plus l'importance du multilatéralisme et
la nécessité d'une autonomie stratégique
européenne
sous présidente française du Conseil de
l'Union européenne ces derniers mois ont
été l'occasion d'avancer historique la
facilité européenne de paix a été
utilisée pour aider directement un pays
attaqué à se défendre nous avons acté
notre volonté de renforcer les
investissements européens en matière de
défense avec l'adoption de la boussole
stratégique nous sommes engagés
collectivement lors du sommet de
Versailles en mars à réduire nos
dépendances
ce conflit a marqué le réveil
géopolitique de l'Europe nous savons
désormais qu'il nous faut peser pour
faire valoir nos valeurs et notre modèle
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ce
conflit dur mais il devra trouver une
issue
après la guerre l'Ukraine devrait être
libre et souveraine après cette guerre
la Russie sera toujours notre voisine
elle est et restera une grande puissance
seule la diplomatie permettra de trouver
une sortie durable à ce conflit c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous maintenons des
canaux d'échanges avec la Russie
des négociations devront se tenir quand
l'Ukraine estimera le moment venu et
quelle sera en mesure de faire
pleinement entendre sa voix
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
cette guerre a bousculé beaucoup de nos
certitudes elle a changé profondément et
durablement l'ordre mondial
elle a rappelé que la démocratie est un
acquis fragile et que nos valeurs
devaient être défendues alors avec
l'Europe avec les alliés la France
restera aux côtés de l'Ukraine jusqu'au
bout nous ne céderons rien face à
l'agresseur russe et nous continuerons
toujours à protéger les Français je vous
remercie
merci madame la Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
je vais donc donner la parole aux
orateurs des groupes premier orateur le
président Christian Cambon pour le
groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
le président
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
lorsque le mur de Berlin est tombé le
monde qui avait toujours connu la guerre
froide a vécu un tournant historique
combien d'entre nous aurait pu imaginer
il y a 30 ans que nous vivrions un
nouveau tournant aussi important avec le
retour de la guerre en Europe et le
nouveau contexte international qu'elle
installe pour les décennies à venir
je voudrais aborder avec vous ce débat
majeur en suivant trois axes de
réflexion tout d'abord les principaux
enjeux que ce conflit de ce conflit dont
les partisans des thèses russes
voudraient nous faire croire qu'ils ne
concerne que deux voisins ce qui n'est
évidemment pas la réalité ensuite je
pense qu'il est important de rappeler à
nos compatriotes pourquoi et comment la
France s'est engagée aux côtés de
l'Ukraine
enfin il est important d'examiner les
conséquences que ce conflit a pour notre
propre pays pour nous approvisionnements
énergétiques et pour nos forces armées
après 245 jours de combat la lutte des
Ukrainiens face à l'agression russe a
radicalement changé de visage
elle apparaissait au départ comme un
combat pour l'honneur perdu d'avance
aujourd'hui elle tient en échec l'une
des armées les plus puissantes au monde
et devient une légende à laquelle
personne n'aurait cru mais nous savons
aussi le prix payé par ce peuple
courageux et nous nous inclinons ces
instants devant tant de souffrance
devant tant de mort et de martyrs
victimes de la folie humaine qu'un jour
mes chers collègues qu'un jour justice
leur soit rendue
non l'Ukraine n'a pas sombré sa bravoure
sa solidarité ses qualités militaires et
sa détermination l'ont maintenu à flot
face à une brutalité d'un autre âge elle
s'est révélée à elle-même au monde mais
surtout à Vladimir Poutine et à son
régime car si nous en sommes là c'est
parce que dans leur vision dévoyée de la
Russie éternelle la nation
ukrainienne n'existe pas
pour les dirigeants russes l'Ukraine
n'est une partie de l'empire qu'ils
veulent ressusciter sur toute sa sphère
historique leur irrédentisme prétend
ramener chaque russophone dans le giron
d'une mère patrie magnifique et donc
dépêcher les pays dans lequel ils vivent
c'est bien là que le conflit
ukrainien plonge ses racines
en 2016 Vladimir Poutine avait affirmé
je cite que les frontières de la Russie
ne se terminent nulle part
nous avons eu tort de ne pas voir en ces
mots un programme sinistre d'autant
qu'il avait déjà commencé à l'exécuter
oui nous avons été aveugles au signaux
de l'ambition russe et 20 dernières
années conflit gelés écrasement de la
Tchétchénie attaque de la Géorgie
annexion de la Crimée
occupation du don de basse crise après
crise nous avons fait le pari du
dialogue avec Moscou nous l'avons fait
ici même au Sénat jusqu'en 2021 et il
fallait le faire mais les dérives du
régime ont été les plus fortes
le 24 février fut un réveil brutal et
dramatique mais certains en France même
ne se sont-ils pas encore ne sont-ils
pas encore dans ce plonger dans ce
sommeil stratégique ce choc a été aussi
un révélateur le multilatéralisme ces
règles ces institutions qui ont organisé
notre vie internationale depuis tant
d'années sont entrés dans une crise
existentielle
le conflit ukrainien a mis en pleine
lumière les mouvements tectoniques de
l'ordre international ils sont amples
ils sont violents ils dessinent une
nouvelle géographie des rapports de
force où se confront dorénavant deux
systèmes de pensées et de valeur dans ce
face-à-face le pouvoir russe peut
compter sur le soutien des régimes qui
lui ressemblent expansionniste
autocratique violent comme lui il
fonctionne par la terreur et écrase
toute contestation comme lui il rejette
l'État de droit les libertés publiques
la séparation des pouvoirs comme lui il
méprise le droit international s'assoit
sur la souveraineté des États et voit
dans la force un moyen légitime de
parvenir à leurs fins
dès lors pourquoi la France doit
s'engager aux côtés de l'Ukraine
il est des moments où ne rien faire
devient le plus grand des risques voilà
ce qui est en jeu nous aidons l'Ukraine
parce que la Russie veut nous imposer
par la violence une Europe soumise les
faits sont là il y a 8 mois la Russie a
envahi un pays voisin et souverain
l'Ukraine ne l'a menaçait pas mais
entendait simplement tourner son regard
et aussi son avenir vers l'Europe et son
modèle démocratique Oni par Vladimir
Poutine et les régimes autoritaires pour
ces raisons notre détermination ne peut
pas elle ne doit pas faiblir
ni dans notre soutien à Kiev ni dans nos
sanctions à l'encontre de Moscou des
voies s'expriment pour suggérer leur
modération voir leur abandon c'est en
fait l'Ukraine qu'elle propose
d'abandonner et donc aussi la défense de
nos intérêts pour certains autres nos
livraisons d'armes retard de
l'inévitable et accroissent
inutilement les souffrances des
Ukrainiens quel drôle d'indécence de
proposer aux Ukrainiens agressés de
tendre l'autre jour de se soumettre à la
fatalité de l'occupation
rappelons-nous mes chers collègues notre
propre histoire et nos épreuves comment
un Français pourrait-il proposer de se
soumettre à l'envahisseur quand la
déraison est la barbarie l'emportent le
rôle d'une puissance d'équilibre n'est
pas de ménager le camp de l'agresseur
bien sûr il faudra vous l'avez dit
madame la Première ministre bien sûr il
faudra un jour négocier mais comme la
rappeler le président Larcher en
recevant le 7 juin ici même le président
de la Rada c'est aux Ukrainiens aux
Ukrainiens et à eux seuls de déterminer
quand comment et dans quelles conditions
les négociations pourront se tenir le
président de la République après avoir
mené une diplomatie du téléphone
abondamment commenté semble désormais
s'être rangé à ce constat mais ce qui
fut perçu au moins comme une ambiguïté a
peut-être brouillé le message de la
France notamment auprès de nos
partenaires de l'Est de l'Europe
à présent ce sont les critiques émises
sur notre aide militaire qui jettent le
trouble notre pays serait très loin dans
le classement des contributeurs à
l'effort de guerre ukrainien nous savons
tous les prix qu'ils accordent à nos
canons César mais ces armes remarquables
ne sont-elles pas l'arbre qui cachent le
désert le gouvernement madame la
Première ministre c'est longtemps
réfugié derrière l'exigence de
confidentialité que nous comprenons pour
ne pas divulguer le détail des
livraisons nous l'avons accepté mais
cette sincérité doit désormais être mise
en cause et je vous donne un tube des
indications que vous venez de donner ce
soir mais nous aurons besoin dans le cas
de la future LPM d'en savoir un tout
petit peu plus ne serait-ce que pour
reconstituer nos propres forces
j'en viens maintenant aux conséquences
de ce conflit elles sont nombreuses et
dans le temps imparti je veux évoquer
deux conséquences qui nous paraissent
importantes qui concerne les secteurs
essentiels de la vie de la nation parmi
les vulnérables les vulnérabilités et
les dépendances que nous ne pouvons plus
accepter le secteur de l'énergie est
évidemment en première ligne face à
l'arme gaziaire maniée par Moscou les
Européens parent au plus pressé dans une
unité réelle mais de plus en plus
fragile or notre continent est entré
dans une crise de sécurité énergétique
qui va durer quoi qu'on en pense
l'énergie nucléaire sera donc
incontournable la France faut historique
lui a tourné le dos en décrétant en 2015
que sa part dans notre mix énergétique
devait baisser ou en actant en 2018 la
fermeture de 14 réacteurs ces appels
n'ont toujours pas été corrigées quant à
l'Europe elle s'obstine à ignorer le
rôle central du nucléaire dans la
transition énergétique c'est aveuglement
ne doit plus durer offrir un véritable
bouclier énergétique aux Français c'est
d'abord garantir l'indépendance de notre
propre production
seconde conséquence majeure les
implications pour nos forces armées la
leçon du conflit ukrainien et limpide
dans ce contexte si vous n'avez pas
d'armée apte à défendre vos frontières
vous êtes une proie l'Arménie paix
charmant aujourd'hui cette leçon et nous
aurons l'occasion ici de révoquer son
cas
mais l'excellence de nos militaires ne
suffit plus en réalité nos armées ont
été éreintés par 30 ans de saigner
budgétaires leur format taillé au plus
juste convenait à une pratique
expéditionnelle auront pu à des combats
rudes mais asymétrique leur masse est
aujourd'hui insuffisante pour tenir dans
la durée un affrontement de très haute
intensité certains affirment même qu'en
cas d'engagement majeur nos armées
n'auraient pas les moyens de tenir
efficacement un front de plus de 80 km
en Ukraine la ligne de front je le
rappelle est de 1000 km nos stocks ne
nous permettent même pas d'aider comme
nous le voudrions un pays a mis
lorsqu'il est agressé un seul exemple
fin 2025 nous aurons en stock
l'équivalent en munitions de ce qui est
tombé la semaine dernière sur l'Ukraine
nous en sommes au point où nous devons
aussi nous demander si notre soutien
militaire à Kiev même insuffisant ne
dépouille pas à l'excès nos propres
forces et donc monsieur le ministre des
Armées tiro maintenant ensemble les
enseignements stratégiques opérationnels
et industriels de ce conflit ukrainien
ils sont nombreux et complexes ce sera
nous le savons l'enjeu dans la prochaine
loi de programmation militaire
se pose aussi la question centrale de
nos coopérations l'Europe se réveille de
sa torpeur stratégique elle entend se
réarmer et ne s'interdit plus de penser
à sa souveraineté tant mieux mais cette
prise de conscience se fait pour
l'instant à l'ombre du parapluie
américain et de son industrie de défense
ne nous méprenons pas le temps reste
notre alliance la plus solide la seule à
vrai dire à pouvoir garantir notre
sécurité collective il était donc assez
prévisible que les Européens cherchent à
s'abriter derrière le bouclier
Atlantique dans cette tempête d'autant
que sur le flanc est le danger n'est pas
simplement en Ukraine ainsi la
Biélorussie de lucachenko marche dans
les pas de Vladimir Poutine et s'invente
des menaces lituanées au polonaises à
ses frontières n'oublions pas cependant
tous ces biélorusses courageux qui sont
opprimés par un régime tout autant
tyrannique
que nous avons reçu avec le président et
vous aussi chers collègues dans cette
hémicycle a réussi à fédérer
l'opposition biélorus pendant ce temps
ne l'oublions pas son mari est en prison
il est torturé les destins de la
Biélorussie et de l'Ukraine ne peuvent
être envisagés de façon séparée agissons
pour que les voix de l'opposition
biélorusse
résonnent davantage au Conseil de
l'Europe au sein de l'Union européenne
et même en France soutenons aussi la
Moldavie menacée de l'intérieur par la
présence russe en Transnistrie et de
l'extérieur par sa dépendance totale au
gaz russe aujourd'hui même la Moldavie
ne peut plus payer son gaz la Moldavie
c'est notre voisinage immédiat c'est un
pays qui a vocation a rejoindre un jour
l'Union européenne a eux aussi nous
devrions fournir des moyens pour assurer
leurs défenses et leur indépendance
comme ils le cessent de nous le demander
dans ce contexte l'Alliance atlantique
est capitale mais elle n'est pas la fin
de l'histoire pour la défense de
l'Europe nous devons être prêts nous
Français nous Européens à faire face
seul parce que nous y serons peut-être
contraints serait-il demain face à des
menaces que Washington déciderait
d'ignorer ou ne pourrait plus traiter
parce qu'elle serait déjà engagée
ailleurs je suis convaincu que nous
avons une perspective européenne commune
en matière militaire mais c'est un
chemin long et sinueux nous en savons
quelque chose même pendant la présidence
française de l'Union européenne nous
n'avons pas vraiment réussi à persuader
nos partenaires en particulier allemand
de s'y engager résolument avançons donc
ensemble partout cela est possible mais
avançons seul partout cela est
nécessaire
c'est pourquoi la prochaine loi de
programmation militaire va être
fondamentale l'actuel loi et je lui je
n'en donne acte au président de la
République a permis de stopper
l'hémorragie celle qui s'annonce devra
porter une ambition plus forte encore
elle devra projeter notre modèle d'armée
dans cette nouvelle aire de menace
mes chers collègues à l'heure où se à
l'heure de se débat l'avenir n'est
malheureusement pas écrit et même
l'apocalypse nucléaire ne peut être
exclue bien sûr tout doit être entrepris
pour ne pas en arriver à cette ultime
extrémité notre dissuasion est une
garantie de sécurité il faut le rappeler
à chacun et ne pas oublier que sa portée
vient aussi de ce qu'elle comprend de
menaçant ou d'un certain veillons donc
veillons donc à ne pas l'affaiblir en
révélant d'emblée une absence de réponse
française
face au poids des incertitudes gardons
le cap mes chers collègues la puissance
russe a volé la paix aux Ukrainiens elle
a tenté de le roter leur liberté et leur
souveraineté c'est bien les plus
précieux que possède un peuple l'Ukraine
doit les recouvrer et nous devons y
aider neons rien à la violence ne cédons
rien aux menaces rien aux mensonge
n'offront pas au Kremlin l'aubaine de
nos divisions et opposant lui un front
uni de démocratie forte et déterminée en
Europe et au-delà c'est bien sûr notre
intérêt mais par-dessus tout ce sera
l'honneur de la France merci monsieur le
président
[Applaudissements]
c'est le président
canner pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
n'avait la parole monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Madame ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues en juillet dernier j'ai
eu l'honneur de faire partie de la
délégation qui est accompagné le
président du Sénat en Ukraine j'étais
profondément marqué par notre visite
dans la banlieue nord de Kiev touché par
les offensives russes nous sommes rendus
dans les villes martyrs dire pin boutcha
personne personne ne peut en revenir
indem
lors de ce court séjour nous avons
mesuré l'importance de l'aide militaire
sans laquelle les Ukrainiens ne se
battraient pas à armes égales avec leur
agresseur comme j'ai pu le dire au-delà
du symbole le soutien sur place
d'autorité politique d'État étrangers
permet la reconnaissance et
l'affirmation de la juste cause du
peuple crânien car de quoi
débattons-nous aujourd'hui nous notre
sujet et le retour de la guerre en
Europe le retour de la guerre c'est le
retour des heures sombres l'ensemble du
projet européen que nous avons bâti
avait pour but d'empêcher que le
continent ne subisse de nouveau les
affres de la guerre et le monde entier a
souhaité écarter ce risque
des organisations internationales mises
en place et toute la construction du
droit international à l'issue de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale visée à prévenir
une telle situation or le souvenir ancré
dans la mémoire de nos aînés cétiole au
fil des ans et la crainte de la guerre
n'est plus aussi prenante
Aristote disait savoir c'est se souvenir
oui savoir si se souvenir souvenons-nous
de toutes les luttes pour le droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux-mêmes avec ce
souvenir ne pouvant que nous opposer
nous révolter contre l'accaparement de
territoire par la force contre les
atrocités qui sont commises je parle de
crimes de guerre
de crimes contre l'humanité perpétré de
la déportation d'ukrainien de la
déportation de centaines de milliers
d'enfants oui de centaines de milliers
d'enfants Ukrainiens qui servent la
propagande russe qui sont placés dans
une famille et qui pensent que leurs
parents sont morts
ne sont pas nouvelles l'horreur syrienne
aurait déjà dû nous alerter car ce sont
les mêmes acteurs nous nous méprenons
pas d'ailleurs face aux nombreux revers
militaires le Kremlin a nommé à la tête
des opérations à nouveau général
Sergueï suborikin qui était déjà à la
malheur en Syrie et dont la sanglante
réputation n'est plus à faire plus la
situation est critique plus les forces
russes sont acculées plus la folie
meurtrière est mortifère de Poutine
s'affirme
comme me l'a dit Robert balinter avec
qui j'ai eu l'honneur d'échanger voici
48 heures je le cite les empires ne
survivent pas aux défaites et Vladimir
Poutine le sait
la population ukrainienne est sacrifiée
traumatisée ce traumatisme se transmet
de génération en génération j'en suis le
témoin
je ne peux qu'avoir une pensée pour ses
morts tomber dans les terribles guerre
du passé en rêvant à la concorde et la
paix du monde une pensée pour ces
quelques personnes qui ont survécu et
qui condamnent d'avance tous ceux qui
tenteraient de devenir les nouveaux
chevaliers de l'apocalypse une pensée
pour les jeunes générations
d'aujourd'hui qui attendent un bon droit
une humanité meilleure une amie
krainienne me confiait l'autre jour à
Lille qu'elle avait découvert le
sentiment de haine
rendons-nous compte ce que cela implique
Kennedy proclamé l'humanité devra mettre
fin à la guerre ou c'est la guerre qui
mettra fin l'humanité le monde
arrivera-t-il jamais à changer la
mentalité belliqueuse qui a tissé
jusqu'ici ne si grande partie de son
histoire
il est difficile de le prévoir mais il
est facile d'affirmer que notre chemin
doit être celui d'une histoire pacifique
et résolument humaniste Vladimir Poutine
devra répondre de ses crimes de guerre
et contre l'humanité car tout a une fin
mais en attendant la crise devient la
norme et l'escalade de violence russe ne
semble pas connaître de limite la menace
est désormais nucléaires qu'elle soit
tactique ou stratégique l'Ukraine est au
cœur oui d'une escalade très inquiétante
et la Russie est tentée de durcir la
situation avant l'hiver les avancées
militaires étant toujours plus
difficiles dans les contrées gelés
cependant la population ukrainienne
aussi connaîtra les plus grandes
difficultés les frappes massives contre
les infrastructures sont sur le point
d'entraîner un effondrement énergétique
il semble même que les victoires
ukrainiennes sont comme un stimulant
pour la Russie
la même Russie ne souhaitant plus subir
de défaite sans répliquer de manière
puissante cette escalade est mortifère
ainsi suite au retrait ruche de Kerson
de nouvelles menaces notamment la
destruction du barrage de carrosca se
font jour aujourd'hui et menaces
et la menace de la frappe nucléaire est
encore très présente ses chantages sont
autant de pions avancés dans le jeu de
terreur d'intimidation des populations
visant à leur saper le moral on le sait
la guerre ne se gagne pas uniquement
avec les armes alors oui le peuple
craignant est résilient oui il va de sa
liberté de sa souveraineté mais
participats des forces de guerre ne doit
pas être uniquement synonyme de
fournitures d'âme par la France l'aide
humanitaire madame ministre doit être
pensée organisée mise en œuvre aussi
notre groupe se prononce pour la
création de fonds spéciaux pour venir en
soutien aux populations civiles qui sont
les premiers à souffrir par ailleurs des
incertitudes quant à la réaction de
certains demeurent dans notre monde
interconnecté certaines attitudes
interrogent
la Chine est l'Inde qui semble avoir
pris leur distance avec la Russie lors
du Conseil de sécurité doivent nous
apporter plus de transparence plus de
garanties dans ce domaine le Parti
socialiste a toujours été très clair
vis-à-vis du pouvoir russe et notre
réponse a toujours été la même la
condamnation nous nous rangerons
toujours du côté de la paix je tiens
également à évoquer la question du
Belarus bien être fait par le président
Cambon qui est resté dans l'angle mort
des préoccupations de nos opinions
publiques ce pays a lui aussi une
histoire européenne trempée dans le sang
du sacrifice de l'Est de l'Europe durant
la Seconde Guerre mondiale un quart de
sa population de ce pays a disparu dans
l'ombre de la Russie hier et dans celui
de l'actualité ukrainienne depuis huit
mois ce pays a été par trop oublié il
est réapparu dans le médias lorsqu'il
Alexandre lucaschenko dont nous nous
recommençons plus la légitimité depuis
2020 a compté sur la fébrilité des
dirigeants européens il a uniquement
organisé la venue aux frontières de
l'Europe de centaines de migrants pour
jouer d'un chantage inédit
il aura fallu cet épisode des événements
récents susceptibles de modifier le
cours du conflit pour que l'on ne résume
plus Minsk à des accords qui portaient
des espoirs aujourd'hui déçus car le
Belarus c'est aussi un peuple à qui un
homme un poste sa loi par des élections
truquées un peuple qui a vu emprisonner
arbitrairement plus de 1000 prisonniers
politiques pour briser une contestation
populaire inédite un peuple dont le
dictateur a fait sortir son pays de la
neutralité militaire en autorisant la
présence de missiles nucléaires russes
sur son territoire et qui a récemment
pris le chemin d'une participation
active par une préparation de
mobilisation qui ne dit pas encore son
nom
démocratie du Kremlin ne trompe personne
les référendas organisés dans quatre
régions ukrainiennes à la fin du mois de
septembre avec des résultats fantoche
avoisinant les 100% n'étaient que de
simples formalités des hommes armés
accompagnaient les électeurs au bureau
de vote quand il y en avait l'Union
européenne et le temps d'ailleurs
qualifié ces scrutins
le droit international doivent être
sanctionnées mais en attendant on a
tendance les habitants de Kerson du
louganx de saporizia et de dieudonnex
sont considérés par les Russes comme
faisant partie du territoire de la
fédération de Russie nous sommes tous
d'accord je le pense dans cette
hémicycle pour affirmer notre soutien au
peuple ukrainien mais aussi pour
exprimer une pensée particulière pour
toutes celles et tous ceux qui en Russie
refusent cette dérive historique de leur
dirigeants souvent en péril de leur vie
cette résistance là mérite aussi tout
notre respect
mes chers collègues le comportement
russe et funeste pour l'Ukraine pour
l'Europe mais aussi pour l'ensemble de
la stabilité internationale si le monde
entier a conscience des implications de
cette guerre quant à l'ordre mondiale le
rôle de la France et de l'Europe est
particulièrement important nous Aya
américains étant soumis de nouvelles
élections d'ici quelques semaines l'on
ne peut assurer que les moyens déployés
seront renouvelés dans ce contexte
l'Europe et la France constitue un pôle
de stabilité ce qui nous oblige nous ne
pouvons fuir notre responsabilité face à
la guerre et face au monde le Sénat chez
le président peut apporter sa modeste
mais efficace contribution à travers les
relations diplomatiques qui sait
notamment grâce au groupe d'amitié
France Ukraine et je salue sa présidente
la coopération des centralisée pourrait
également jouer un rôle important dès
lors qu'elle serait coordonnée
la France a pris sa part madame la
Première ministre en affirmant sa
volonté de solution diplomatique dans le
passé pas si lointain en 2014 sous
François Hollande a été mis en place
qu'on appelle le format Normandie qui
réunifie les différents acteurs durant
la guerre du gambas la France est alors
en position médiateur pour favoriser un
dialogue et trouver une sortie de crise
l’année suivante la suspension de la
livraison de Mistral à la Russie pour
protester contre l'annexion de la Crimée
n'a pas été une décision facile à
prendre j'étais à leur gouvernement et
je me souviens des oppositions de
certains ce type d'initiative est à
travers elle l'affirmation de notre
volonté pacificatrice et du rôle que la
France peut jouer dans l'ordre mondiale
me semble déterminant d'autant que
Vladimir Poutine compte sur nos failles
mais quand sera-t-il si notre engagement
perdure
l'acceptation de la position de la
France a-t-elle des limites nous savons
que nous sommes à un moment charnière
les revers militaires russes
s'enchaînent je l'ai dit mais Poutine se
durcit nous devons donc nous mobiliser
encore plus une autre menace m'inquiète
la menace de l'habitude la menace de la
lassitude si la crise devient la norme
si le non-respect de la souveraineté des
peuples ne nous révoltent plus alors
nous nous dirigions tout droit vers un
monde où la loi du plus fort régnerait
alors mes chers collègues sachant
construire la victoire de l'intelligence
contre l'obscurantisme sachant
construire la victoire de l'humanité
contre la barbarie sachant construire la
victoire du droit contre la force et
pour y parvenir madame la Premier
ministre et au nom des collègues qui
suivent particulièrement ce dossier je
voudrais vous poser cinq questions
précises
tout d'abord
je souhaite bien comprendre les propos
tenus par Emmanuel Macron le président
de la République dimanche dernier à
savoir et je cite une paix possible
celle-là seule que les Ukrainiens
décideront quand il le décideront
faut-il comprendre que les Ukrainiens
restent seuls la responsabilité de la
paix et à quel prix en termes de
frontières
deuxième question l'Ukraine demande plus
d'armes mais combien pouvons-nous encore
en fournir nos stocks ne sont-ils pas
menacés
troisième question en cas de
déclenchement de l'arme nucléaire quel
serait notre capacité notre volonté de
réponse et quelle mesure de sécurité
nucléaire ont été mises en oeuvre
quatrième question sous quelle forme la
France apporte son soutien direct à la
population ukrainienne notamment à
l'approche de la période hivernale et
enfin quelle nouvelle initiative
diplomatique la France entend prendre
mais chers collègues merci pour votre
attention même le Premier ministre merci
pour vos réponses
merci monsieur le président
je vais donner la parole maintenant pour
le groupe de l'Union centriste à notre
collègue Nadia sologobe je veux saluer
son engagement comme présidente du
groupe d'amitié un engagement déterminé
et particulièrement concret
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Madame la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'Ukraine n'est pas en guerre
depuis le mois de février 2022 l'Ukraine
est en guerre depuis février 2014 date
d'annexion de la Crimée elle est même en
conflit avec son
elle est même en conflit avec son grand
frère russe depuis les années 30 date de
Lolo de mort que nous commémorons le 29
novembre prochain et termination par la
fin d'environ 5 millions de victimes par
la volonté de Staline alors grand maître
du Kremlin qui avait choisi de piller le
grenier à blé de l'Union soviétique pour
financer son industrialisation
l'Ukraine et la Russie sont peut-être en
guerre depuis fort longtemps
oui mais voilà jusqu'à présent cela ne
nous dérangeait pas depuis février 2022
la guerre de l'Ukraine a mis fin pour
nous aux dividendes de la paix cet
événement central a bousculé tous nos
arbitrages économiques et politiques
comme un voile qui se déchire l'invasion
de l'Ukraine par la Russie nous a permis
de voir les fractures déjà à l'oeuvre
dans le tissu économique et social
français la guerre à martelé comme le
covid le message de l'impréparation de
la France sa vulnérabilité en général
face aux chaînes de valeur des secteurs
stratégiques essentiels la question des
ressources et des approvisionnements
s'est posée avec brutalité
désormais les enjeux de sécurité sont
devenus prioritaires la question de
l'engagement militaire de la France et
centrale j'ai eu la chance d'être
présente à la Rada le jour où les
députés ukrainiens ont longuement
applaudit la France le président Larcher
et n'ont qu'anon César moment
inoubliable nous examinerons bientôt le
projet de loi de finances 2023 premier
budget depuis le déclenchement de de la
guerre en Ukraine nous souhaitons savoir
quels moyens ils seront prévus pour la
poursuite de l'aide à l'Ukraine le
Parlement dont il est évident qu'il doit
être tenu au courant de l'effort de
guerre ressent madame la Première
ministre une forme de frustration face à
ce que je qualifierais d'opacité sur la
question des volumes précis et du type
d'être fourni
on annonce un nouveau paquet militaire
vous nous en avez parlé nous aimerions
savoir ce qu'il contient précisément des
chiffres circulent sur ce qui pourrait
être le montant financier total de notre
aide militaire mais c'est de vous madame
la Première ministre que nous devons
avoir une information fiable et précise
qui permettent également de situer
l'importance de notre effort par rapport
à celui des autres nations nous
demandons à être informés de façon
régulière ce qui ne remet pas en cause
bien évidemment notre soutien et
particulièrement celui du groupe
centriste à votre action les derniers
développements des combats sur le sol
ukrainien nous laisse penser que cette
situation n'est pas transitoire et
malgré des avancées ukrainiennes nous
avons devant nous un conflit qui
s'installe et sera long l'offensive
ukrainienne ralentit la mobilisation
partielle décrétée par Vladimir Poutine
va apporter aux Russes à renfort humain
massif même si les nouveaux soldats
seront globalement mal équipés et peu
motivés il nous faut donc désormais nous
donner des moyens durables de faire face
au conflit de haute intensité sur le sol
national et sur le sol européen
aujourd'hui la situation militaire est
loin d'être stabilisée plus l'armée
russe recule et plus le risque
d'élargissement du conflit est tangible
madame la ministre face à un risque
d'escalade nucléaire brandis par le
président Poutine qui parle de façon
récurrente ces derniers jours de bombe
sale quel est le plan du gouvernement
quelle préparation en France pour les
populations civiles à l'heure où les
comprimésdiotes sont en tension
d'approvisionnement mondiale quels abris
atomiques alors que les agences de
notation évoquent le risque nucléaire
dans certains scénarios comme s'il
s'agissait désormais d'une nouvelle
normalité cette guerre est
l'accélérateur d'une redistribution des
grands équilibres géopolitiques mondiaux
nous prenons conscience de façon aiguë
du positionnement stratégique national
européen et mondial nous sommes à
l'heure des choix face au risque
d'embrasement général en Asie centrale
où le groupe Wagner tente de recruter
quel est le rôle de la France pour
empêcher l'extension du conflit au pays
voisins comment aider ces pays à
construire leur propre autonomie
stratégique entre la Russie la Chine ou
la Turquie quelle est la politique de la
France vis-à-vis de cette région cette
guerre est aussi une guerre d'images il
est nécessaire que la France participe à
la mise en lumière des crimes russes
envers les civils Ukrainiens le monde
doit connaître les exactions dont se
rendre coupable les Russes et leurs
milices en Afrique et plus
particulièrement au Sahel ou les soldats
russes sont considérés comme des
libérateurs la France doit couper court
à la désinformation le resserrement de
l'Alliance atlantique ne doit pas
empêcher la France de faire entendre sa
voix à ce ça de mon propos je ne veux
pas en mettre la question de l'énergie
car la crise géostratégique s'est
transformée en crise énergétique avant
de se transformer en crise économique le
prix du gaz entraîne mécaniquement celui
de l'électricité il n'y a plus de long
terme dans le champ des factures
énergétiques la concentration européenne
semble buter actuellement sur ces sujets
les entreprises sont dans des situations
intenables les collectivités également
et de nombreux particuliers ris de
basculer dans la précarité quelle est la
stratégie de la France dans la recherche
de fournisseurs intermédiaires d'énergie
comment le gouvernement est-il en train
d'organiser le long terme de
l'approvisionnement et énergétique
national
si nous avons désormais compris que
l'énergie
l'énergie n'est pas une évidence
l'alimentation non plus
les perturbations de la production
agricole des chaînes d'approvisionnement
et des échanges commerciaux
[Applaudissements]
si nous avons désormais compris que
l'énergie n'est pas une évidence
l'alimentation non plus les
perturbations de la production agricole
des chaînes d'approvisionnement et des
échanges commerciaux ont donné lieu à
une envolée des prix mondiaux des
denrées alimentaires et des engrais à
des niveaux sans précédent
la Russie en faisant de l'alimentation
une arme dans sa guerre contre l'Ukraine
a provoqué une crise mondiale de la
sécurité alimentaire voilà ce que vient
de déclarer le Conseil européen
madame la ministre il est réellement
vital d'obtenir à ce stade que les
corridors céréaliers de la mer Noire
reste ouvert au-delà du mois de novembre
la spéculation sur les marchés
agroalimentaires et leur dérégulations
étaient prévisibles c'est le grenier du
monde qui est visé
en France la crise covid avait accéléré
la demande d'une consommation
alimentaire de proximité de qualité
rémunérée au juste prix la guerre et son
cortège de difficultés économiques pour
les ménages les amènent désormais hélas
à privilégier l'alimentation à moindre
coût et nos producteurs en font les
frais
tous les marchés ont été perturbés mais
il nous faut faire la part des choses
n'oubliez ni les phénomènes spéculatifs
ni les difficultés préexistantes de
notre économie même s'il a tendance est
de rendre le conflit russeau ukrainien
responsable de toutes nos difficultés il
y a toujours eu les hélas ceux qui
baptisent des fortunes en temps de
guerre dans ce contexte de panique et
d'angoisse maximale de l'opinion
publique il y a un enjeu fort tenir bon
Poutine espère précisément que les
Français se lassent de ce conflit aux
conséquences lourdes ils ne doivent pas
céder le président rodezieux le disait
il y a quelques jours à Nevers les
entreprises françaises souffrent mais
quel que soit le prix à payer le Medef
soutient les sanctions car les valeurs
morales éthiques et philosophiques n'ont
pas de prix elles sont le pré requis
d'un contexte économique garant de la
stabilité des entreprises
au-delà de ce constat il nous faut
marteler qu'à ce stade du conflit il ne
s'agit plus d'une guerre entre la Russie
et l'Ukraine mais bien d'une guerre
entre un agresseur et un pays souverain
dont l'intégrité territoriale est en
cause d'une guerre entre un pays qui ne
respecte plus aucune convention
internationale et l'Occident qui se
posant défenseur du droit humanitaire
international la France pays des droits
de l'homme doit être inflexible face au
crime contre l'humanité qui sont
perpétrées chaque jour en territoire
occupé frapper des infrastructures
civiles en temps de guerre c'est un
crime de guerre déporté massivement des
enfants se devrait être un crime de
guerre et je ne pars ni des viols ni du
traitement inhumain des blessés des
populations civiles contraires à tous
les engagements de la Convention de
Genève que dire de toutes les atrocités
perpétrées sciemment contre des
populations innocentes et des armées les
récits les témoignages les images sont
trop nombreux ils sont poignants
incontestables et insupportables la
vision des appartements d'irpine passés
au lance-flamme par l'armée russe ne
n'hésitera jamais le Conseil européen
vient de prendre une position très ferme
l'agresseur devra rendre des comptes
dit-il nous serons les témoins de demain
mais notre rôle aujourd'hui est d'aider
le monde à trouver le chemin de la paix
madame la ministre la conséquence la
plus évidente de ce conflit pour la
France et les Français et d'avoir amené
la guerre à portée de voiture les élus
de nos communes et les Français ont
généreusement ouvert leurs portes des
familles celle de nos voisins
impressionnant de courage et de
résilience il les prennent en charge et
les soutiennent chaque jour sans compter
l'invasion de l'Ukraine a provoqué un
renforcement de certaines valeurs qui
doivent rester un socle commun vous
aurez compris comment groupe
collectivement m'a demandé de porter un
message de fermeté de soutien intangible
au peuple ukrainien de dénonciation des
crimes de guerre dans le prolongement du
débat de ce soir Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres le Sénat souhaite être votre
partenaire de chaque jour dans cette
crise majeure à titre personnel
j'exprime ma solidarité à nos collègues
et amis de la Rada ukrainienne et leur
président rusland stevenchouc qui ont
vaillamment siéger sans discontinuer
depuis février 2022 parfois sous les
bombes j'ai une pensée profondément émue
pour toutes les victimes de conflit je
vous remercie malgré toutes les
conséquences que cela emporte de nous
assurer vous l'avez fait ce soir que la
France restera pour l'Ukraine un soutien
indéfectible et fort jusqu'au jour tant
espéré celui de la paix
merci ma chère collègue
j'ai donné la parole maintenant à notre
collègue André catholin pour le groupe
du Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre madame et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues en
préalable à mon propos je voudrais tout
d'abord saluer la tenue ce soir de ce
débat ici en hémicycle car si la guerre
en Ukraine déclenchait par la Russie il
y a maintenant huit mois traverse toutes
nos discussions de toutes nos
commissions parlementaires sans
exception nous n'avons jusqu'à présent
guéru l'occasion d'en débattre
solennellement en hémicycle avec le
gouvernement il y a certes eu la
déclaration devant le Sénat du 1er mars
dernier suivi d'un débat où chaque
groupe politique a pu s'exprimer mais si
je puis me permettre beaucoup d'eau
depuis à couler sous les ponts de Paris
et sous les ponts du nièpre ou du moins
ce qu'il reste de pont sur ce très
majestueux fauve européen la
responsabilité de cette éclipse du débat
parlementaire un con moins au
gouvernement et à notre assemblée qu'un
calendrier électoral absurde qui lors
des années d'élection présidentielle les
législatives suspendent nos travaux en
hémicycle durant plus de 4 mois
une situation il faut le dire qui ne
valorise guère aux yeux de nos
concitoyens la démocratie parlementaire
notamment en période de graves crise qui
conduit l'exécutif à prendre des
décisions importantes sans consultation
formelle du Parlement alors je veux donc
ici et ce soir saluer la présence
conjointe aux bancs de la première
ministre et d'une partie du gouvernement
qui forte heureusement ont tenu
régulièrement informés notre commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
défense armée de l'évolution de la
situation mais comme nous le rappelait
pas plus tard qu'il hier soir le
ministre des Forces armées il est
essentiel que l'information percol
auprès de l'ensemble de la
représentation parlementaire nous y
voici donc un ministre car si certes
notre pays n'est pas en guerre il se
trouve néanmoins aujourd'hui
indirectement très impliqué dans ce
conflit et nous en mesurons chaque jour
les conséquences multiples tentent à
l'échelle de la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens qu'à l'échelle de notre
nation et de celle de l'Europe à ce
propos et à ce stade du débat je
concentrerai mon intervention autour de
deux grands points en forme de constat
provisoire bien sûr qui appelle chacun
quelques questions premier premier
constat la guerre en Ukraine qui vient
s'ajouter à la crise sanitaire agit
comme un révélateur des fragilités et
dépendances de notre économie comme là
clairement révélée le rapport du CESU de
mai dernier notre appareil productif et
face à deux problèmes majeurs la hausse
des prix de l'énergie et des matières
premières et les ruptures
d'approvisionnement qui menacent d'arrêt
certaines activités et tous les secteurs
de notre économie sont affectés il y a
d'abord l'envolée du prix de gros de
l'électricité qui est quasiment été
multipliée par 12 en 1 an il y a aussi
la pénurie des composants électroniques
apparu durant la crise sanitaire qui se
trouve aujourd'hui aggravée par le
conflit
ukrainien
15 septembre les usines de les usines
Renault du Nord étaient à l'arrêt en
raison des difficultés
d'approvisionnement en semi-conducteur
citons également les ruptures de stock
dans l'agroalimentaire passer de 2% à
plus de 10 % sans parler du domaine de
l'armement et des moyens capacitaires de
nos armées qui appellent d'importantes
réorientation et les investissements
élevés alors compte tenu de nos
contraintes budgétaires et aussi
humaines quelles sont mesdames messieurs
les ministres les secteurs que vous
estimez les plus prioritaires et les
échéances que vous vous fixez pour
acquérir une autonomie assez
significative dans ces domaines
second constat présent malgré les chocs
subis forcé de constater l'admirable
résilience de l'opinion française face à
la propagande et au narratif russe selon
son agifop paru au début de ce mois on
note que si les Français sont
majoritairement inquiets des
conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine
pour la France ils sont cependant 70%
avoir une bonne opinion de l'Ukraine
compte 16% seulement pour la Russie on
observe surtout que les deux tiers des
Français se déclarent favorables
fonctions économiques et approuvent la
livraison d'armes à l'Ukraine par
l'Europe pour autant et très tôt une
petite musique s'est propagée sur les
réseaux sociaux et parfois dans des
médias plus officiels sous-entendant que
toutes les difficultés actuelles des
Français proviendraient de du soutien
que nous portons à Kiev un choix qui
nous aurait insidieusement été inoculée
par une Amérique fortement prédatrice
au fil des ans il faut le dire la Russie
est passée maître en matière de
désinformation et de Guerry brides il
faut en l'état se féliciter de son
relatif échec à déstabiliser notre pays
et son opinion publique les services de
l'État en matière de lutte contre les
attaques cybers et de lutte contre la
désinformation chez aussi très notamment
vigilant créé il y a un nom ont depuis
le début de la guerre beaucoup
contribuaient à endiguer l'offensive
international de la Russie il serait
injuste ne pas leur accorder un
sacrificité très mérité l'Europe n'a pas
non plus été en reste la création
récente d'un système de signalement des
tentatives de désinformation par la
strat 2 du service européen pour
l'action extérieure a déjà montré son
utilité mais c'est sans doute
l'interdiction de la diffusion sur tout
le territoire de l'Union de RT news et
de Spoutnik décidé dès les premières
semaines de l'agression russe qui a le
plus d'impact dans ce combat pour autant
il ne faut pas négliger d'autres
facteurs extérieurs notamment il faut
bien le dire la faiblesse du narratif
poutinien pour justifier l'attaque
contre l'Ukraine en particulier les
accusations de nazisme et
d'antisémitisme proférés à l'endroit de
Kiev et de la population du pays
également la défection de nombreux
hackers qui gravitaient dans la
nébuleuse russe de cyber-combattants et
qui ont souvent rallié le camp ukrainien
et l'AS batnat list le très efficace et
percutant contre narratif ukrainien
développé par le président voleur
d'immer Zelinski et son entourage la
figure de héros de la liberté et de
résistant à l'oppresseur celle aussi de
David contre Goliath n'échappe ici à
personne et donne sur la forme un sacré
coup de vieux à la commission politique
partout dans le monde mais la guerre de
l'information contre la France est plus
généralement contre les pays
occidentaux n'est pas encore gagné un
potentiellement très difficile ajoutez
un possible en lisant de la guerre
pourrait sérieusement affecter la
solidarité actuelle de l'opinion à
l'égard de l'Ukraine contenu en France
et en Europe le narratif autoritaire de
la Russie c'est fortement redéployé et
accentué en Afrique en particulier
contre notre pays RT news et Sputnik se
développe à une vitesse grand V et
partout sur le continent la nébuleuse
Wagner de l'oligarquegny pruggosine
déploie notamment à travers sa société
de production filmique au room un
narratif pro russe qui connaît un très
vif succès auprès des populations les
plus jeunes et les plus populaires
d'Afrique avec ses effets néfastateurs à
l'encontre de nos soldats de nos
diplomates et de nos entreprises
notamment au Mali en République
centrafricaine récemment au Burkina Faso
et sans doute nos mains en Guinée
mesdames messieurs les ministres notre
pays fait d'ores et déjà face à un
second front aussi quelles sont les
mesures que nous comptons mettre en
oeuvre pour gagner la guerre de la
communication qui se mène contre nous en
Afrique mais aussi en moyenne Orient je
vous remercie merci mon cher collègue
je vais maintenant donner la parole au
président Pierre Laurent pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste
sur le président de la parole
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre Madame et Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues le 24
février Vladimir Poutine ordonnait
l'invasion illégale de l'Ukraine par
l'armée russe violent le droit
international et l'intégrité d'un État
souverain il déclenchait un conflit
d'une ampleur inédite depuis 1945
qui appelle notre solidarité auprès du
peuple ukrainien
illégal et terriblement meurtrière cette
guerre ne connaît depuis février que
l'escalade elle menace aujourd'hui la
sécurité internationale
cette guerre c'est à ce jour selon le HR
8 millions d'ukrainien réfugiés à
l'extérieur de l'Ukraine des millions de
déplacés intérieurs plus de 15000
victimes civiles tuées ce sont des
dizaines de milliers de morts au combat
ukrainiens et russes ce sont des crimes
de guerre et c'est la répression des
dissidents et des conscrits en fuite la
genèse des deux pays et chaque jour
fauchée dans les combats la guerre c'est
l'effondrement du moitié du PIB
ukrainien la destruction du tiers des
infrastructures énergétiques le Premier
ministre ukrainien annonce déjà quand
l'État le coût de la reconstruction se
chiffrera en centaines de milliards de
dollars la guerre c'est l'aggravation de
la crise économique et énergétique
partout sur la planète frappant d'abord
les plus faibles c'est le spectre de la
famine comment Somalie ou le monde de
nourriture tuera aussi sûrement et même
plus que les bombes
cette guerre c'est l'engloutissement
quotidien de ressources considérables
qui manquent tant aujourd'hui pour
répondre aux défis du développement
humain et du changement climatique c'est
l'aggravation catastrophique des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre qui
bat en brèche tous les objectifs
climatiques la nouvelle dépendance de
l'Europe OGN américain deux fois et demi
plus émetteurs de CO2 que le gaz naturel
on est un exemple frappant la guerre
c'est l'embrassement possible à tout
instant en Moldavie en Géorgie est déjà
à l'oeuvre en Arménie avec l'attaque
azéri ce sont tous les points de tension
du globe ravivé le spectre d'un nouveau
conflit mondial le retour de la menace
de la nihilation nucléaire
Moscou réinterprète dangereusement la
grammaire de sa dissuasion
et la surenchère peut mener de manière
irresponsable à l'éventualité d'un
conflit nucléaire s'est fait alarmant
devrait d'ailleurs inviter à renoncer de
la manière la plus vigoureuse qui soit
les discussions mondiales sur le
désarmement multilatéral et un régime
d'interdiction des armes nucléaires la
guerre entre la Russie l'Ukraine et
derrière elle les forces de l'OTAN est
un terrible engrenage
dont nous aurons nous le savons beaucoup
de mal à sortir faut-il dès lors se
résigner à l'escalade
sauf à accepter de voir simplifier la
catastrophe en cours pour des semaines
des mois et peut-être des années encore
nous pensons madame la ministre qu'il
faut avoir madame la Première ministre
qu'il faut avoir le courage de ne pas
abandonner l'exigence d'un Cécile feu le
plus rapide possible sur le front dire
cela scdo russe comme on l'entend dire
comme s'il s'agit d'accepter de geler la
situation sur la ligne de front actuelle
bien sûr que non dire cela c'est demandé
que dans la guerre la voix de la paix et
de la diplomatie ne s'éteignent pas et
qu'elle reprenne la main au plus vite
sans accepter le terrible prix humain
d'une amplification de cette guerre une
guerre alors qu'il est sans perspective
de faim et probablement sans vainqueur
parmi les peuples nous voulons le retour
de la diplomatie pour tracer le chemin
d'une négociation globale récusant le
changement de frontières et
l'acquisition des territoires par la
force demandant le retrait des troupes
russes rouvrant le dialogue sur
l'autodét la garantie de souveraineté et
de sécurité pour tous les peuples à ceux
qui préconisent la guerre et donc
aujourd'hui forcément son escalade avec
toutes ses conséquences imprévisibles en
faisant miroiter sa fin prochaine je
demande de me dire dans quel pays la
guerre a fait 30 dernières années
apportées la solution et la paix promise
on Afghanistan on Iraq en Syrie en Libye
au Yémen au Sahel tous ces pays sont en
ruine et on prend au vol aux violences
et pourtant les ennemis étaient tout
aussi condamnables non la voie de la
diplomatie pour la paix n'est pas celle
de la reddition elle est peut-être celle
de l'espoir celle qui épargne au peuple
la misère la destruction et la barbares
et la barbarie
nous livrons des armes à l'ukraines et
malgré nos demandes répétées la
Parlement ne dispose pas à ce jour de
toutes les informations ni sur ce que
nous livrons ni sur les incidences de ce
livraison sur nos propres capacités de
défense
qui peut daigner tant que la guerre dure
un état agressé comme Ukraine le droit
de se défendre et de faire appel pour
cela à ses alliés
personne mais qui peut assurer que ces
livraisons même massives ou verront la
voie la solution militaire du conflit en
cours alors quel que soit les décisions
prises à ce propos rien ne doit nous
détourner d'un effort immédiat pour
retrouver la voie de la paix par la
négociation internationale au plus vite
le président de la République a eu
raison le 12 octobre sur France 2 et ce
dimanche en Italie de remettre dans le
débat cette perspective de la paix et du
retour à la table de négociation mais il
semble dans le même mouvement on
repoussé toujours l'échéance nous
pensons que la France avec d'autres doit
y travailler sans tarder que pensez-vous
madame la Première ministre de la
proposition d'un ancien ambassadeur de
France hier dans un grand journal du
soir d'engager sans tarder entre
ukrainiens et alliés une discussion sur
que devrait être un calendrier et une
solution et une position de négociation
que pensez-vous des voix qui s'élèvent
par exemple dans une tribune d'anciens
diplomates italien s'exprimant sur les
bases possibles d'un règlement négocié
ou qui s'exprime dans la lettre adressée
par 35 démocrates de la Chambre des
représentants à Joe Biden pour
l'anjouindre de déployer de vigoureuses
efforts diplomatiques en soutien
règlement de négocier que pensez-vous
des déclarations du pape François que le
Président de la République viendront
rencontrer et qui n'a cessé d'appeler à
ce que les armes se taisent depuis le
début du conflit pour avancer dans ce
sens et parce que nous savons que le
chemin est rempli d'obstacles nous
pouvons travailler à conforter tous les
Écores partiels déjà négociés pour
élargir les brèches je pense à l'accord
sur les exportations de céréales qui
prendra qui arrive à échéance le 22
novembre allons-nous travailler à sa
reconduction
est-il également possible de conforter
l'accord sur la sécurisation des
centrales nucléaires en lien avec l'ONU
et la IEA comment agir pour permettre
l'action des organisations humanitaires
alors que le droit international
humanitaire est toujours lui parfois
comment assurer la protection
d'installation civile
indispensable aux populations la
priorité est également de prévenir
l'extension du conflit au pays
frontaliers
un engagement réciproque des partis
prenantes doublés d'un engagement
multilatéral à ne pas impliquer de
nouveaux pays frontaliers dans la guerre
pourrait être un objectif
au-delà l'objectif doit bien être celui
de rouvrir une négociation globale de
sécurité sous l'égide de l'OSCE
madame la Première ministre pour toutes
ces raisons nous pensons que la France
devrait entamer la construction d'une
grande coalition mondiale pour la paix
qui ne peut être enfermé dans le sol
bloc de l'OTAN la logique des blocs
d'ailleurs fait partie du problème qui
nous voit par exemple en ce moment
s'embargner classer la Turquie l'Arabie
Saoudite et des gouvernements d'extrême
droite européens dont le camp de la
démocratie
de nombreux pays qui refusent
l'alignement derrière la Russie mais
aussi derrière l'OTAN souhaite une telle
coalition de la paix qui se donne pour
but la construction commune et Mondiale
de la Paix par la construction de
sécurité collective et de sécurité
humaine alimentaire sanitaire
énergétique climatique partagée la
France devrait en prendre l'initiative
nous devons pour cela parler à des
grands pays comme l'Inde ou comme la
Chine
sans les jeter dans les bras des Russes
comme certains le font à des pays plus
modestes comme en Asie centrale comme le
Kazakhstan le Kirghizstan l'Ouzbékistan
qui sont intervenus à plusieurs reprises
pour critiquer la guerre nous devons
parler à des pays africains menacés par
les conséquences de la guerre et qui
veulent un ordre mondial plus juste et
plus solidaire sans avoir à choisir
entre deux systèmes de domination pour
constituer cette grande coalition la
France doit reprendre sa liberté
d'initiative pour assumer pleinement en
Europe et dans le monde son rôle au
service de la paix merci
merci monsieur le président
donner maintenant la parole au président
Claude malure pour le groupe Les
Indépendants républicains et territoires
avez la parole
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres le 1er mars
dernier alors que les troupes russes
encerclées Kiev et qu'on nous expliquait
que l'Ukraine serait écrasé en quelques
jours je commençais mon discours à cette
tribune par la phrase suivante
l'invasion de l'Ukraine sera le premier
clou sur le cercueil de la dictature de
Poutine
cette perspective parait sans doute
moins irréaliste aujourd'hui
le césarisme appuyait sur une propagande
sans limite et un nationalisme guerrier
et la recette de toutes les dictatures
jusqu'à ce qu'elle fasse le pas de trop
pendant 20 ans Poutine mise en pratique
le proverbe arabe un chameau se mange
par morceaux une pâte au moment de la
Tchétchénie une jambe avec l'oscéty une
cuisse avec l'aprasie et la suite
Transnistrie Crimée bombasse devant
notre inaction il s'est dit qu'avec
l'Ukraine il pouvait manger le chameau
d'un seul coup il est en train de mourir
d'indigestion
il y a peu d'exemples dans l'histoire où
l'agresseur soit parvenue avec autant de
précisions à l'exacte contraire du but
recherché Poutine voulait annexer
l'Ukraine il en a forgé la nation
divisez l'Europe il la soudé ridiculiser
le temps il l'a renforcé humilier les
États-Unis il a ressuscité Biden après
Kaboul prendre la tête des dictatures la
Chine s'inquiète la Turquie montre les
dents le Kazakhstan et toute l'Asie
centrale en profite pour prendre le
large conforter sa dictature par ses
conquêtes les troubles commencent dans
les républiques de la Fédération de
Russie elle-même démontrer l'isolement
de l'Occident 143 pays à l'ONU contre 4
sanctionne la Russie
condamne la Russie il est acculé
stratégiquement économiquement
militairement que va-t-il faire tout
simplement ce qui sait faire ce qu'il a
toujours fait un conflit gelé à ses
frontières puisque l'Ukraine ne peut
franchir la frontière russe et une
guerre hybride contre l'Occident pour y
semer le chaos
ce chaos ceux qui vont s'en charger chez
nous ce sont les officines les
populistes les collabos et leurs réseaux
sociaux qui depuis des années relaient
avec une fidélité canine sa propagande
100% poutinien hier il tente de sauver
les meubles aujourd'hui ils attendent
l'hiver ils savent que l'opinion est
capricieuse il compte que le soutien à
l'Ukraine se désagrège leur leitmotiv
c'est beurre fromage comme en 40 en
clair la Russie même pas mal les
sanctions ne font souffrir que l'Europe
tous les chiffres qu'ils cite sont faux
endroits de ligne du Kremlin
une récession russe de quelques
pourcents nous dit-on non seulement
l'absence de microprocesseurs empêche
les Russes de reconstituer leur armement
mais il ne fabrique même plus de
voitures ou de machines à laver les 700
000 gommes qui ont quitté le pays depuis
février les plus qualifiés entraîne un
effondrement de la production 1000
entreprises étrangères ont quitté le
pays représentant 40% du PIB la Bourse
de Moscou a perdu
50%. les économistes de salon qui nous
disent que le rouble n'a pas baissé
n'ont toujours pas compris que son cours
officiel est bidon puisqu'il n'est plus
échangeable qu'ils aillent dans une rue
de Moscou et change quelques dollars au
noir ils apprendront que le rouble dans
le monde réel a perdu 50% de sa valeur
50%. tous les chiffres venant de l'État
russe sont comme Lénine dans son
mausolée soigneusement entretenu et tout
à fait mort
les sanctions marchent
les gens sont marchent et de mieux en
mieux le prochain axe de la propagande
russe c'est la paix
nous venons d'ailleurs d'en avoir un
exemple à l'instant à chaque conflit
avec l'Occident l'URSS puis la Russie a
recouru au même stratégie le pacifisme
dans les années 30 c'est le mouvement
pour la paix orchestré par les parties
communistes européens et les idiots
utiles les Sartre Aragon et les autres
qui a désarmé les démocraties dans les
années 80 les missiles russes à la
frontière de l'Europe et la riposte des
pierchings Américains contrecarrés par
les immenses manifestations plutôt rouge
que mort rappelons-nous la phrase
cruciale de Mitterrand les missiles sont
à l'est les pacifices sont à l'ouest qui
a fait échouer la manœuvre
et bien et bien c'est reparti on n'a pas
fait assez attention au thème de la
conférence de presse de Le Pen la
porte-parole salariée du Kremlin il y a
quelques jours il faut organiser une
grande conférence pour la paix en Europe
la manœuvre va s'amplifier
Mélenchon ne dit rien d'autre et pour
cause ils prennent leurs ordres au même
endroit leur groupe ont ensemble refusé
de voter les sanctions et l'aide à
l'Ukraine et nous venons d'en écouter à
l'instant les arguments hélas il va donc
nous falloir redoubler d'efforts pour
les convaincre pour les combattre et
pour convaincre les Français de
continuer leur soutien le seul côté
positif de la guerre en Ukraine c'est
qu'elle nous ouvre les yeux les
dictateurs sont revenus certains les
avaient cru vaincus à jamais à la fin du
20e siècle sous nos yeux l'international
des tyrans se reforment pour se venger
abattre l'Occident mettre à Balad la
démocratie malgré les erreurs
catastrophiques de la Russie
Moscou Pékin puis en gang et d'autres
renforcent leur lien sous le regard
attentif d'Ankara la guerre de Poutine
n'est qu'un prélude les prochaines
générations doivent savoir coudre la
crise climatique le vrai défi le vrai
défi à venir sera la menace des
dictatures sous la conduite de la Chine
la deuxième guerre froide a commencé si
nous en sommes là c'est aussi à cause de
nos propres lâchetés ce qui s'est passé
ce n'est pas dans des places à Fukuyama
la fin de l'histoire c'est la sortie de
l'Europe de l'histoire il n'y a pas de
phrase plus malheureuse que celle qui
nous a convaincu que nous allions je
cite toucher les dividendes de la paix
elle nous a conduit à fermer les yeux
depuis 20 ans à chaque nouvelle exaction
de la Russie a laissé la Chine piller
nos technologies et escroquer l'OMC elle
conduit nos dirigeants à répéter
aujourd'hui que nous ne sommes pas en
guerre
erreur tragique car les dictateurs eux
savent qu'ils sont en guerre contre nous
il le disent
cette erreur majeure d'analyse fut
d'abord celle de l'Allemagne et de la
France depuis un demi-siècle la
politique allemande défendait sur la
dépendance énergétique vis-à-vis de la
Russie la dépendance économique à la
Chine et le désarmement face aux deux
celle de la France fut le courtiser la
Russie pour trianguler sa relation avec
les États-Unis en croyant acquérir une
position indépendante sans en avoir les
moyens militaires les avertissements de
l'Europe de l'Est qui sait elle ce que
sont les dictatures ont été rejetées
avec mépris l'invasion de l'Ukraine nous
montre l'échec de ces deux politiques et
surtout l'urgence à ne pas les
poursuivre il est plus que temps de
renforcer la coalition de toutes les
démocraties et d'abandonner en France la
lentille américanisme appuyait sur la
vieille haine de droite contre les
anglo-saxons et la vieille haine de
gauche contre le capitalisme le tout au
nom d'un gaullisme de pacotille
ignorant ce que disait de Gaulle
l'anti-américanisme et le socialisme des
imbéciles il est plus que temps de
moderniser et renforcer les défenses
européennes pour se hisser à la hauteur
de la compétition stratégique de
comprendre que les guerres à venir
seront hybrides et que notre retard dans
le numérique la lutte contre la
désinformation et l'intelligence
artificielle est encore plus immense que
notre dans les armes conventionnelles il
est plus que temps en fin de hausser le
ton face au boucher de Moscou la France
et l'Allemagne donne parfois en Europe
centrale l'impression d'un soutien
distancié si l'aide militaire est réelle
le discours est parfois plus hésitant la
volonté exprimée de ne pas humilier les
veines tentatives de dialogue
l'insistant sur la nécessité de
négociation le moment venu alors que
meurt par milliers les Ukrainiens risque
de brouiller la perception de notre
engagement toute négociation qui
prendrait place avant le retrait total
des Russes de l'Ukraine aboutirait à la
même situation que celle de l'abrasie de
l'océi du Dombas et de la Crimée
c'est-à-dire un nouveau conflit gelé la
poursuite des guerres hybrides à l'est
de l'Europe et en définitive une
victoire de Poutine la seule façon
d'apporter à long terme la paix et la
stabilité sur notre continent c'est la
victoire de l'Ukraine et la défaite de
Poutine ce n'est pas seulement
l'indépendance de l'Ukraine qui se joue
aujourd'hui mais la sécurité de toute
l'Europe et l'unité Indis responsable du
monde libre contre les dictateurs je
vous remercie merci monsieur le
président
la parole
est au président Jean-Claude Roquier
pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président
monsieur le Président Madame pour la
première ministre Madame et Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues depuis le
24 février dernier le premier jour de la
question de l'Ukraine par la Russie
lardissan des Ukrainiens n'a jamais
cessé une résistance admirable et
durable que Vladimir Poutine n'avait
sans doute pas
récemment sous-estimer
courage résilience et détermination sont
les ingrédients d'une force morale qui
ne faiblit pas ni au sein de la
population ni au sein de l'armée
ukrainienne du courage il en faut pour
affronter la puissance militaire russe
et si centaines de milliers d'hommes il
en faut pour voir rétablir la réalité
d'un pays libre souverain face à
l'Histoire révisée et mensongère de
Poutine la résilience
les draps humains le ciel de Mario Paul
la tragédie de moutcha les bombardements
d'infrastructures civiles jusqu'au cœur
du territoire tout cela est difficile à
vivre et ne manquera pas de laisser les
traces malgré tout pour le moment rien
même le pire entamé la détermination des
Ukrainiens c'est avec c'est égal
détermination que le président selinski
endossé le rôle de chef de guerre sa
volonté samsaye confortée par le soutien
matériel diplomatique de nombreux pays
occidentaux permet à l'Ukraine de tenir
mieux que cela le pomme de terre est
capable
de bousculer et même de renverser le pot
de fer courant en septembre l'armée
ukrainienne a fait des remarquable
reconquête dans le nord-est ainsi que
dans le sud du son pays cela a été
rappelé la ligne de front a bougé en fer
de l'Ukraine dans la région de quartier
notamment et vers Kerson au sud c'est
aussi on ne peut que les suer bien
entendu mais disons-le aussi elles ont
un revers les effets de l'humiliation de
Vladimir Poutine face à ses échecs c'est
affront le connais sans cesse à
l'escalade jusqu'à l'utile menace celle
de brownies régulièrement l'art
nucléaire n'oublie pas les manipulations
qui a érigé un art de guerre taire que
la dernière autour de la prétendue bombe
sale dans ces conditions qu'elle doit
être notre attitude que peut-on espérer
aujourd'hui
mal après le ministre le groupe RDSE
adhère à la ligne assez consensuelle qui
saucissent qui consiste à vouloir
arrêter ce conflit sans devenir
belligérant nous soutenons les efforts
consentis par la France et l'Union
européenne pour aider l'Ukraine à se
défendre dans la même temps nous
apprenons nous approuvons aussi le
régime sanction bien que son impact soit
relativement limité sur l'économie russe
conviennent révéler le récemment
pronostic du FMI néanmoins tout doit
être tenté pour maintenir la Russie au
bain des nations car c'est pas seulement
l'intégralité territoire d'un pays qui
est en jeu est également la vision de
monde libre contre celle de
l'impérialisme autorité le discours
stupéfiant de séries la brosse à l'ONU
puis celui du président Poutine prononcé
lors de sa cérémonie d'alexion du 30
décembre dernier ont été un peu plus
clairs
ont été d'une rare violence
plus personne ne doute aujourd'hui du
rosier par Moscou de nos valeurs à la
question peut-être du président Victor
Hormann ce dernier oubliait peu vite les
chars soviétiques qui ont écrasés dans
le sang en 1956 des milliers de ses
concitoyens faut-il lui rappeler pour
que la Hongrie la diverge pas du cadre
démocratique auquel elle est censée
appartenir mais chaque collègue faudra
avoir marché sur Kiev en quelques jours
comme les foyers sont scénario initial
le président russe s'enferme dans la
guerre c'est à l'isement porte le risque
de nous enfermer aussi déjà les
conséquences économiques et énergétiques
qu'elles provoque à l'Europe et même
au-delà impact nos concitoyens
alors qu'à la fin de la pandémie c'est
entrevoir en retour à la croissance la
physique-crégnienne entraînait une
inflation galopante et les tensions sur
nos capacités énergétiques nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir lors de l'examen
du projet de finance pour 2003 beaucoup
de mesures sont sur la table pour faire
face à ces défis mais nous savons que
l'équation budgétaire sera difficile à
résoudre comment les filles un effet
domino le conflit menace aussi la
cohésion européenne les débats au
dernier conseil européen ont été tendus
je sais par la première ministre que la
France ne mélange pas ses efforts pour
maintenir l'union européenne l'unité
européenne notamment autour du projet de
plafonnement du prix de gaz une mesure
nécessaire
mais l'Allemagne réticente de plus en
plus berlien Berlin fait cavalier seul
et regarde vers l'est c'est une
inquiétude c'est pas d'ailleurs aussi
concernant la défense monsieur le
ministre a volonté allemande
d'harmoniser en Europe le contrôle de
l'exportation des armements dans un sens
qui lui serait clairement favorable mais
contraire aux intérêts industriels et
stratégiques de la France les voies
divergent également sur la question du
négociation vous l'avez rappelé dans la
première ministre le président de la
République souhaite maintenir le
dialogue avec Moscou un choix parfois
critiqué par les pays de l'Est mon
groupe favorable aux discussions
d'autant plus que Washington a considéré
le mois dernier qu'elle pourrait être la
solitude en attendant nous devons rester
derrière l'Ukraine par le fournissant
les arbres dont on a besoin dans les
fameux canons César aux performances
remarquables et remarqués
le 4 mai 1939 dans le journal l'oeuvre
le socialiste pacifiste Marcel da et là
futur pillée de la collaboration puis il
y a un éditorial au moment où
l'Allemagne menaçait la Pologne intitulé
Pourquoi mourir pour la musique dans ce
contexte de guerre aux portes de
l'Europe les Français seront-ils prêts à
se priver pour Kiev l'avenir le dira
cependant le courage extraordinaire de
nos amis Ukrainiens leur sacrifices la
sacrifice et leur valeur démocratique
ils sont si chères imposent aux Français
un devoir moral de soutien d'aide et de
solidarité
merci monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
donner la parole au président Guillaume
Gontard pour le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoire
que le président
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres
depuis plus de 8 mois le peuple
ukrainien résiste et héroïquement pardon
à l'impérialiste russe depuis quelques
semaines son armée a inversé la tendance
sur le terrain et commencer à repousser
l'envahisseur vers la frontière russe
qui aurait imaginé ce scénario quand en
février les colonnes de blindée russe
descendaient sur Kiev et que l'on
proposait au président Zelinski un soft
conduit pour quitter le pays
Goliath a des pieds d'argile et David
lourdement armé par ses alliés et
beaucoup plus grand que ce que l'on est
compté la guerre est installée dans tout
le sud et l'est du pays et durera encore
des mois alors que l'hiver s'apprête à
geler des positions le bilan humain qui
malgré les difficultés d'estimation ce
chiffre au moins à plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de morts et de blessés et va
continuer là ça s'alourdir les civils
Ukrainiens payent également un lourd
tribu victime des bombardements massifs
des attaques des drones kamikazes et des
crimes de guerre en tout genre de
l'occupant russe qui fuyant devant la
percée ukrainienne a laissé comme un
bout de chat d'atros chante d'atroces
charnier des fosses communes mal
dissimulées qui réjuste le cœur et
l'esprit
dans ces audieux massacres de civils les
femmes ont comme souvent été victimes
d'abominable violence sexuelle
pramia Patten Représentant du Secrétaire
général de l'ONU considère que le viol
en Ukraine est bel et bien une arme de
guerre une stratégie militaire visant à
déshumaniser les victimes et à
terroriser la population
les quelques victimes recensées parmi
tant d'autres restés anonymes entre ont
entre 4 et 82 ans effroyable
l'armurerie ne recule devant aucune
barbarie pour tenter de saper le moral
du peuple ukrainien elle bombarde
toujours un distinctement les civils et
distinctement les réseaux électriques
pour semer la terreur l'inconfort et le
froid madame la Première ministre à ce
jour l'Ukraine ne demande pas d'aide
pour réparer les réseaux électriques
mais le cas échéant la France et
l'Europe sont-elles prêtes à envoyer des
techniciens et des groupes électrogènes
pour éviter qu'une partie de la
population
ukrainienne connaissent un hiver glacial
acculé la Russie ne recule devant rien
bombardements d'infrastructure civile
mobilisation partielle loi martiale
menace nucléaire répétée balistique mais
aussi civile il semblerait qu'à l'heure
où nous parlons les inspecteurs de
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique n'est plus axé à la centrale de
sa poridja ce qui est comme depuis le
début du conflit une source d'inquiétude
aiguë cette épée de Damoclès au-dessus
de nos têtes est insoutenable plus que
jamais le monde doit s'engager vers la
fin du cauchemar nique nucléaire pour
citer une fois n'est pas coutume le pape
François je vais vous faire lui notre
demande d'adhésion de la France en tant
qu'observateur au traité sur
l'interdiction des armes nucléaires
du Clément du Kremlin joue sa survie et
a entraîner le conflit au-delà d'un
point de non-retour un monde en paix ou
Vladimir Poutine demeure président de la
Fédération de Russie est une chimère
nous l'avons laissé agir en Géorgie nous
avons laissé agir en Syrie nous l'avons
laissé agir en Crimée et cela doit
cesser l'Ukraine doit gagner cette
guerre cette victoire sera atteinte
quand l'Ukraine aura recouvré ses
frontières de 91 dombases compris Crimée
comprise ou quand elle décidera que ses
objectifs militaires sont atteints toute
tentative de médiation avec le dictateur
russe semble veine Poutine refuse le
dialogue et ne comprend que le rapport
de force la position française des
derniers mois a parfois dérouté le
gouvernement ukrainien comme nombre de
nos partenaires européens nous demandons
au président de la République de ne plus
tergiverser de cesser d'invoquer comme
un mantra une hypothétique table de
négociation cette rhétorique de
médiation pas de sens la France est trop
engagée dans le conflit pour tenir ce
rôle Vladimir Poutine se considère de
toute façon en guerre contre l'Occident
que nous le voulions ou pas le rôle de
la France est celui d'un soutien ferme
et sans ambiguïté à l'Ukraine au droit
international à la démocratie à nos
valeurs et à la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique tributaire de la
victoire de l'Ukraine et des démocratie
un soutien plus ferme dans ces mots un
soutien plus ferme dans ses actes la
France qui est la première armée
d'Europe qui prône l'autonomie
stratégique du continent doit porter son
effort d'aide à l'Ukraine à la hauteur
de l'ambition géopolitique qui est la
sienne à la hauteur de notre voisin
britannique qui forme 20 000 soldats
Ukrainiens qu'on nous en formons 10 fois
moins à la hauteur de nos voisins
allemands qui vivent des chars d'assaut
au pays d'Europe de l'Est pour que
ceux-ci puisse aider leur charte
soviétique à l'Ukraine pour limiter les
dégâts des drones iraniens le 12 octobre
dernier le président de la République
annoncé que la France allait fournir à
l'Ukraine des systèmes antimissiles pour
se protéger notamment des drones
iraniens vous nous confirmez aujourd'hui
que cette promesse sera tenue cette
fermeté doit aussi s'adresser à nos
entreprises qui continuent leur activité
en Russie au premier rang desquels total
énergie qui contribue indirectement à la
fourniture en kérosène de l'armée russe
et donc au bombardement de la population
civile l'énergéticien doit quitter la
Russie il fait honte à notre pays quand
ces homologues occidentaux ont tous
annoncé abandonnés leur activité en
Russie il s'enrichit indument grâce à
l'explosion des cours du pétrole et du
gaz un véritable profiteur de guerre
comme le dénoncer bravage le président
de la République en juin dernier au G7
madame la Première ministre comment
pouvez-vous dans ces conditions refuser
encore et toujours de taxer les super
profits des profiteurs de guerre
allez-vous au moins faire votre
l'excellente proposition de notre
collègue Boris Vallaud et des députés
socialistes de saisir pour les verser à
l'Ukraine tous les dividendes et autres
gains que les entreprises auraient perçu
en demeurant sur le sol russe nos
dépendances à l'énergie russe continue
d'être notre talon d'Achille dans cette
bataille l'Allemagne dépend de son gaz
nous dépendons de son uranium entre 2000
et 2020 la France a importé de Russie 19
245 tonnes d'uranium naturel et 8213
tonnes d'uranium enrichis nous importons
près de la moitié de notre du Kazakhstan
pays militairement lié à la Russie le
dernier arrivage de Russie connu 52 fut
d'uranium enrichie date du 24 août
dernier le prétendu la prétendue
souveraineté coffre le nucléaire est une
vaste farce le régime de sanctions
européennes empathie et notre effort est
loin de ce qu'il devrait être asphyxié
et économiquement la Russie l'heure pour
les quais pour le continent pour le pays
est à la souveraineté et à la sobriété
énergétique et vous l'avez rappelé celle
que seul procure le soleil le vent et
l’eau à condition de doter l'Europe de
filières industrielle en capacité
d'assurer sa transition énergétique
aucun plan européen aucun projet de loi
français pour excellerer le
développement des énergies renouvelables
n'atteindra ses objectifs si nous ne
sommes pas capables de nous équiper
nous-mêmes avec le plan de leur relance
nous équiper nous-mêmes pardon avec le
plan de relance américain avec les
nouveaux objectifs du gouvernement
chinois la demande intérieure de
panneaux solaires des deux plus grandes
économies du monde va exploser l'Europe
va pouvoir produire les siens plus
rapidement ce sont les mesures de
sobriété que nous devons développer
votre gouvernement a fait quelques
promesses en la matière mais qui repose
et qui repose encore beaucoup trop sur
le volontariat des entreprises il faut
davantage de contraintes les solutions
de coût et de moyen terme sont pourtant
légion cette sobriété d'autant plus
indispensable que la crise énergétique
avait démarré avant la guerre en Ukraine
et se poursuivra après impactant
toujours plus le pouvoir de rive de nos
concitoyens la seule bonne nouvelle s'il
y en a une dans cette période de graves
troubles c'est que les intérêts vitaux
du peuple ukrainien les intérêts vitaux
de nos concitoyens et les intérêts
vitaux du climat se rejoignent voilà un
dilemme de moins sur autre bureau il
faut sortir le plus rapidement possible
des énergies fossiles et décupler nos
efforts en matière de transition et de
sobriété énergétique notre avenir est
intimement lié à celui du peuple
ukrainien merci
monsieur le président
donner la parole pour 3 minutes
maintenant notre collègue Stéphane
Ravier qui n'appartient à aucun groupe
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Madame
le Premier ministre mes chers collègues
Tocqueville affirme que les démocraties
d'opinion sont incapables de stratégie
persévérante la déclaration que l'on
vient d'entendre on est la preuve vous
vous concentrez sur des épiph phénomènes
des postures morales et un décalage de
la crise économique par l'endettement
public mais face à nous madame le
Premier ministre il y a le retour des
empires armé d'une vision sur le long
terme Vladimir Poutine est
constitutionnellement au pouvoir
jusqu'en 2036 si Jean Ping véritable
empereur en Chine menace Taïwan en Corée
du Nord la dynastie des Kim mûrit sa
puissance depuis 1948 en Iran le néo
sultanat affirme ces velléités
nucléaires dans le Caucase l'ex Empire
ottoman ambitionne de reconstituer au
détriment de la nation souveraine
arménienne et de son peuple sans parler
de l'émergence des puissances nucléaires
que sont l'Inde et le Pakistan le 21e
siècle se profile comme un siècle de fer
de feu et de sang
depuis plus de 30 ans l'Occident s'est
perdu dans l'euphorie de la chute du mur
de Berlin pourtant depuis tant
d'événements nous ont alerté sur la
persistance de la guerre Koweït
Yougoslavie 11 septembre Afghanistan ira
Crimée et à islamique tension
indopacifique malgré cela rien ne fut
fait pour reconstituer notre puissance
au contraire s'il y a bien une française
qui connaît le rationnement et la fin de
l'abondance depuis des décennies c'est
notre armée elle a été victime de
l'idéalisme de nos gouvernants dans les
principales illusions furent les
dividendes de la paix l'Europe de la
défense le multilatéralisme onusien la
démission du général De Villiers en 2007
avait pour but de lancer l'alerte sur
l'état critique de nos forces face aux
enjeux du monde le président Macron la
méprisé quant à votre chimérique Union
européenne nous assistons aujourd'hui
encore au divorce du couple
franco-allemand le chancelier allemand
annonçant les fait 100 milliards d'euros
en vue de constituer la première armée
conventionnelle d'Europe et 40 milliards
pour l'achat d'avion F-35 américain
les mêmes qui ont organisé notre
dépendance au gaz russe nous lâche en
pleine crise dans ce contexte nous
devons cesser de déléguer notre
souveraineté et regagner les moyens de
notre indépendance nationale il nous
faut prendre conscience des grands défis
du siècle voir que l'ordre du monde est
régi par l'antique dialogue melien et la
loi du plus fort anticiper les
évolutions industrielles économiques
comme un moyen de ne pas perdre une
guerre du même nom comprendre la réalité
du choc migratoire et du choc
démographique en cours la Turquie et la
Biélorussie avec leur chantage aux
migrants ont bien compris l'intérêt
d'utiliser cette arme contre les nations
d'Europe alors que le président russe
déclare l'Union européenne
courbelligérante vous confirmez madame
le Premier ministre votre souhait de
livrer des armes à l'Ukraine mais sans
vouloir faire la guerre consciente de
notre extrême faiblesse militaire
rapportée par le président de la
commission de défense du Sénat lui-même
qui a déclaré qu'en cas de guerre nous
disposerions de 15 jours de munitions et
pour certains armements
trois ou quatre jours seulement mais ne
doutons pas que les wattes en guerre
indépendants armées de leur salive
troqueront leur costumes en mocassins
pour un treillis ranger et passeront
ainsi des travées du Sénat aux tranchées
des soldats il est toujours temps
d'imaginer madame le Premier ministre
des scénarios de rupture et des profité
de notre position de puissance nucléaire
pour négocier avec les grands sans
naïveter sur l'état de la conclure et
sur les intérêts poursuivis par les
autres États fut-il nos alliés merci
je vais maintenant donner la parole à
Madame la Ministre de l'Europe des
Affaires étrangères madame la ministre
mais c'est le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs dessinateur tout
comme la première ministre les orateurs
des différents groupes qui se sont
succédés à la tribune l'ont tous
rappelés la Russie a fait depuis 8 mois
désormais le choix le choix de ramener
la guerre sur notre continent
cette crise est grave elle ne concerne
tous
l'Ukraine voit sa souveraineté son
intégrité territoriale menacée par
l'agression de la Russie un état doté de
l'arme nucléaire un état qui en tant que
membre permanent du Conseil de sécurité
a une responsabilité particulière pour
défendre le système international et la
Charte des Nations Unies mais qui fait
aujourd'hui le choix de remettre en
cause leur fondement même
cette agression n'est pas soutenue par
la population russe tout le démontre
elle n'évolue que par des gouvernants
pour lesquels le droit et la vérité ne
sont devenus que de simples options
un pouvoir russe qui conduit depuis plus
de trois semaines maintenant des
bombardements massifs contre des cibles
civiles crènes dans tout le pays avec un
objectif assumé casser ses
infrastructures et briser la résistance
du peuple ukrainien en l'exposant au
froid et à la fin alors que l'hiver
approche
à pouvoir russe qui n'hésite pas à faire
des dizaines de millions de réfugiés et
déplacés commet crimes sur crime et
s'enferme dans une impasse diplomatique
militaire et politique
un pouvoir russe qui recouvre mensonge
une nouvelle fois en nous en prétendre
que l'Ukraine s'apprêterait à faire
exploser une bombe sale sur son propre
territoire
nous avons aussitôt dénoncé cette
manipulation et nous y consacrons
beaucoup de nos efforts diplomatiques
ces jours derniers en lien notamment
avec la l'UEA et au Conseil de sécurité
qui devrait en débattre demain à notre
demande
notre détermination ne doit pas vaciller
le président de la République est la
première ministre l'ont appelé nous
soutenons l'Ukraine parce qu'elle se bat
pour des valeurs démocratiques ces
valeurs qui sont les nôtres nous la
soutenons aussi car si nous laissons la
Russie bousculer les principes les plus
fondamentaux de la vie internationale
tout fera permis non seulement en
Ukraine mais ailleurs
en étant l'Ukraine à se défendre nous
défendons les principes essentiels de
non-agression d'intégrité territoriale
de souveraineté et de règlement
pacifique des différents consacré par la
Charte des Nations Unies
nous sommes au côté de l'Ukraine depuis
le 1er jour de l'agression par des
sanctions pour entraver l'effort de
guerre russes et toucher ce qui
collabore avec elle Biélorussie où Iran
nous l'avons fait et nous le referons si
nécessaire et par une aide diplomatique
économique humanitaire et bien sûr
militaire
à l'approche de l'hiver nous accentions
notre soutien humanitaire et préparant
de nouvelles opérations pour répondre à
l'urgence après avoir fait parvenir
récemment par exemple 1000 tonnes d'aide
humanitaire aux populations une part
importante de l'action du Centre de
Crise du ministère de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères il est désormais
consacrés et nous prévoyons la livraison
de générateurs de matériel de chauffage
et de matériel de reconstruction très
prochainement pour environ 50 millions
d'euros de même que nous envisageons la
tenue d'une conférence internationale à
Paris dans quelques semaines pour aider
à la résilience du peuple crainien sur
une initiative du président de la
République
nous sommes aussi aux côtés de l'Ukraine
pour garantir que les auteurs des
exéctions et des crimes de guerre ou des
crimes contre l'humanité soit poursuivie
nous y contribuons en soutenant
concrètement l'action de la Cour pénale
internationale et les enquêtes engagées
par la justice ukrainienne
mais nous sommes également aux côtés de
nos partenaires et de nos alliés face à
la menace que la Russie fait peser sur
leur sécurité c'est l'honneur et la
responsabilité de la France en tant que
première puissance militaire du
continent que d'être présente en
Lituanie en Pologne en Roumanie et en
Estonie où je me suis rendue hier en
accord avec le ministre des armées pour
marquer notre soutien à ce pays mais
aussi pour rendre visite à nos forces
mesdames de sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs la Russie est de plus en plus
isolée
le vote qui s'est tenu à l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies le 12 octobre
là clairement démontré les mois
d'efforts diplomatiques du Kremlin pour
tenter de justifier l'injustifiable ce
sont soldés par une condamnation massive
de l'agression et de l'annexion illégale
de territoire ukrainien
croyez bien que ce résultat est aussi le
résultat de nos propres efforts
diplomatiques et de ceux de nos proches
partenaires
et de même s'il y a une présence de
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique à saporicza contrairement à ce
que j'ai entendu il y a une présence
c'est aussi largement grâce à l'action
du Président de la République et de la
diplomatie française
en aidant l'Ukraine en isolant la Russie
en luttant contre l'impunité nous
faisons notre devoir de solidarité
nous faisons notre devoir d'humanité
nous défendons la sécurité du continent
européen c'est à dire la nôtre et nous
le ferons donc aussi longtemps qu'il
sera nécessaire je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
je vais donner la parole maintenant
Sébastien Lecornu ministre des Armées
monsieur le ministre merci monsieur le
Président du Sénat mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs qui ne me soit permis de
réagir peut-être à quelques propos qui
ont été tenus ici la tribune du Sénat en
remerciant l'ensemble des orateurs en
excusant même la première ministre qui
se rend actuellement à l'Assemblée
nationale
peut-être revenir sur le premier point
qui est une des inquiétudes que le
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères et des forces armées à
relayer au nom de la Commission dans son
ensemble sur lequel j'avais déjà
l'occasion de répondre mais de fait
qu'il me soit permis peut-être de
diffuser cette parole sur l'ensemble de
ces bancs sur le premier la première
question le premier doute angoisse
peut-être que est-ce que nous nous
dépouillons de nos propres moyens
jusqu'à quel point nous abaissons notre
standard de sécurité pour protéger la
France les Françaises et les Français au
fond on le voit bien entre celles et
ceux qui nous invite à donner plus
celles et ceux qui parfois nous invitent
à la prudence ça nous renverra à des
discussions sur évidemment la réalité de
nos stocks mais je pense qu'il faut
quand même le dire un nous ne faisons
pas de session qui mettrait la nation
française en danger mais nous le faisons
avec le pragmatisme qui nous conduit à
regarder la réalité de nos stocks il est
vrai mais aussi la réalité des conseils
que nous donne nos généraux chef
d'état-major de chaque armée évidemment
le chef d'établure des armées deuxième
des choses oui nous en tirons des
conclusions opérationnelles sur la
recomplétude nos canons César ont été si
têtes nombreuses reprises soyez en
remercier c'est un bon cas pratique les
18 canons César qui ont été donnés à
l'Ukraine ont fait l'objet depuis le
mois de juillet dernier d'une nouvelle
commande en recomplétude d'ailleurs le
président de la République visitera
demain à Bourges l'usine Nexter le vrai
sujet c'est mon troisième point cette
fameuse économie de guerre dont la
terminologie peut parfois interroger je
le comprends et je le conçois en tout
cas c'est de se dire oui en haute
intensité il nous faut parfois recompter
nos stocks plus vite et d'une économie
ou d'un système ou d'une filière ou deux
filières au pluriel qui s'était parfois
habitués à des élongations entre l'amont
et Laval désormais et d'ailleurs
l'Ukraine le connaît par le soutien
qu'elle reçoit de l'Occident la Russie à
ses dépenses et c'est tant mieux le
connaît assez propre pour ses propres
problèmes d'organisation on a évidemment
un sujet industriel qui nous faut
traiter on y reviendra avec le Sénat
dans les temps prochain mais notre BITD
comme l'on dit que le fruit de
l'héritage de l'après-guerre célébrer la
pensée demander ce France il y a
quelques jours évidemment du gaullisme
on le voit bien c'était notre capacité à
ne pas être complètement aligné ni sous
Moscou ni sur Washington et demain sur
Pékin et donc cette autonomie
stratégique va désormais aussi
sacrémenter d'une réalité de réactivité
et d'un besoin de réactivité en tout cas
supplémentaire il faut être honnête le
don des canons César a pu déstabiliser
des plans informations sur certains
régiments d'artillerie mais déstabiliser
de la formation pour quelques artilleurs
sont mépris dans mon propos n'a rien à
voir avec le fait d'abaisser le standard
de sécurité pour la France et les
Français deuxième chose sur l'état de
nos moyens mais nous y reviendrons dans
les jours à venir dans le cadre des
discussions sur les produits de finances
bon nous réparons et je pense que c'est
la fierté française de ne pas avoir
attendu l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la
Russie pourra augmenter nos moyens pour
nos armées quel que soit nos opinions
cette décision elle date de 2017 premier
évidemment cycle de la LPM en 2018 je
vous proposerai dans les tout prochains
jours une marche à 3 milliards le
président de la République aura
l'occasion de préciser les futurs
marches sur la copie que nous sommes en
train de d'élaborer avec vous d'ailleurs
par ailleurs mais nous nous laissons pas
guider par les annonces des uns ou des
autres un fond de 100 milliards pour les
Allemands très bien dont acte ils
investissent dans leur défense c'est une
bonne chose les Américains et donc nous
aussi nous avons ces efforts qui sont à
bien des égards similaires et en tout
cas nous n'avons pas attendu une fois de
plus l'invasion de l'Ukraine je ne
serais pas de politique dans 10 ans que
oui nous pourrions donner plus à
l'Ukraine si cette réparation avait
parfois été s'il avait été débuté
démarré bien plus tôt auparavant et que
nous payons effectivement monsieur le
Président comment vous l'avez dit vous
avez raison des coupes successives les
fameux dividendes de la paix comme on
dit si bien des RGPP pour les uns des
diminutions de crédit y compris sur les
diffusion nucléaires pour les autres
autant de sujets qui font de cet LPM une
LPM de réparation mais désormais il va
falloir nous déployer et aller plus loin
avec beaucoup plus d'ambition d'autant
plus c'est là ce n'est pas une affaire
budgétaire mais notre format d'armée
correspond aussi aux menaces lequel
elles ont été confrontées et je le dis
devant la Richard ancien ministre de la
Défense depuis la dissolution du Pacte
de Varsovie ou l'essentiel de leur
emploi c'est fait sur la lutte et pour
la lutte contre le terr rythme
militarisés et que donc par définition
on redécouvre aussi ce qu'est
l'artillerie on redécouvre aussi ce que
sont les tirs en profondeur qui sont
autant de sujets ou autant de techniques
de combat qui avait parfois moins lieu
d'être en Afrique il faut le dire et
donc la recomplétude des stocks la
montée en puissance aussi de nos armées
bah elle tient aussi de cette conclusion
il faudra à la fois dissuader sur le
terrain nucléaire dissuader sur le
terrain conventionnel être capable
toujours de se projeter en Afrique par
exemple sur des missions de lutte contre
le terrorisme là où des pays amis
pourrait nous le demander et en même
temps étant capacité d'assurer d'assumer
nos responsabilités notamment dans le
cadre de l'OTAN on le voit avec le rôle
des armées ça a été dit par quelques
orateurs et je vous en remercie
notamment sur ce que nous faisons en
Estonie la ministre l'a dit mais aussi
bien sûr en Roumanie deuxième
et peut-être aussi de manière incidence
je l'ai déjà dit en commission mais je
le redis ici je réfute ses affaires de
stock qui ferait que je cite l'armée
française ne pourrait tenir que quelques
jours sur un conflit haute intensité
encore moins une ligne de conflit que
l'armée française ne pourrait tenir que
sur 80 km merci au président comment de
me permettre de faire ce revers déjà
parce que c'est créer un doute chez les
Françaises et les Français sur notre
capacité à nous défendre or la voûte
nucléaire et la dissuasion nucléaire qui
d'ailleurs coûte de l'argent et que le
contribuable est appelé évidemment à
soutenir cet effort chaque année depuis
les années 60 produit un effet de
dissuasion précisément plus que c'est
son terme et qu'on ne peut pas le nier
et le balayer d'un revers de main et que
dire que l'armée française pourrait
avoir des difficultés à tenir un front
sur plusieurs jours en se déployant chez
les autres c'est à dire dans le cadre
d'alliance par exemple dans un schéma de
nation cadre n'est strictement rien à
voir et que parfois des journalistique
sont malheureux parce que elles
sous-entendent que notre armée au fond
n'est pas capable de défendre la nation
française et vous le savez pour celles
et ceux qui se sont déployés à leurs
côtés qui n'en est rien donc attention à
ces confusions et je sais qu'à sa Jésus
Sénat pour le coup ne permettra de
rétablir quelques quelques vérités sur
la réalité de l'aide de la France à
l'Ukraine bon plusieurs choses ont été
dites de fait nous assumons la
discrétion parce que évidemment certains
éléments n'ont pas à être donnés à la
Fédération de de Russie que parfois les
Ukrainiens nous demandent eux-mêmes
certains éléments de discrétion et puis
sur les classements tels qu'ils ont été
publiés ici ou là je veux quand même
donner quelques éléments de méthodologie
ces classements en général ne tiennent
compte que de ce qui est déclaré
pas de ce qui est réellement livré on ne
peut pas désobligeant avec certains de
nos alliés et compris très proche de
nous nous je peux m'engager ici devant
le Sénat tout ce qui est promis est
réellement livré et tout ce qui est
livré a été vraiment promis et c'est une
des difficultés que les Ukrainiens
peuvent avoir dans le concours Lépine de
tout ce qui peut être promis je pense
que nous leur devons ça sans cynisme
avec sérieux la deuxième des choses
c'est que parfois tout est amalgamé
certains pays valorisent les coûts de
transport les coûts de formation les
coups de carburant là où nous par
exemple nous le faisons pas certains
pays même dans des ministères de l'OTAN
valorisent leur contribution à l'Ukraine
en tonnage en poids de matériel
réellement donné donc il faut nous
garder aussi de ce virage qui peut nous
amener à manquer de sérieux et donc
évidemment nous nous le faisons sans
signer qu'une fois de plus et je le
crois avec beaucoup de rigueur troisième
chose tout est fait sur la base du
déclaratoire
c'est à dire que beaucoup de choses sont
dites mais non seulement ne sont pas
livrés mais parfois ne sont pas du tout
suivis des faits en termes d'engagement
donc ça évidemment ça pose d'autres
difficultés non la vraie doctrine telle
que le Président de la République a
donné à son gouvernement c'est de livrer
des armes qui sont utiles
nous sommes dans un moment du conflit ou
l'armée ukrainienne a des besoins de
plus en plus spécifiques on a beaucoup
parlé de défense sol r ces derniers
jours d'où la réponse totale que la
France a amené à donner évidemment on a
beaucoup parlé d'artillerie parfois il
est souvent question d'équipements
individuel d'ailleurs parfois non létale
il est clair que le fond de 100 millions
d'euros que le Président de la
République vous proposera d'ailleurs
d'entériner dans la loi puisque il nous
faudra nous autoriser évidemment à le
moment venu ratifier l'ensemble de ces
crédits permet de faire au fond un
costume sur mesure aux forces armées
ukrainiennes et on le voit bien les
premières demandes peuvent concerner des
équipements de parfois des voitures de
transport de troupes
les enjeux de génie pour traverser un
certain nombre de fleuves bref autant
d'éléments très concrets qui évidemment
trouveront leur réponse assez rapidement
enfin je ne serai pas plus long mais je
suis le président du Sénat mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs mais il est
clair que vous êtes revenu à nombreuses
reprises les uns sur Wagner les autres
sur la guerre informationnelle d'autres
sur le chantage à l'énergie on aurait pu
davantage aussi pareil du chantage en
matière première agricole qui concerne
malheureusement beaucoup de pays amis
notamment sur le pourtour méditerranéen
oui nous sommes déjà dans cette drôle de
guerre kellybridité alors est-ce que la
France y est prête oui il existe des
choses je crois que nous avons déjà
rendu compte devant le Parlement de
beaucoup de stratégies qui étaient déjà
entamées deux est-ce que c'est nouveau
oui donc c'est en marchant qu'on apprend
et donc il nous faudra aller plus loin
et le web programmation militaire devra
nous permettre mais d'ailleurs si cette
hybride qu'est-ce que l'hybridité c'est
le détournement de de vecteurs civils à
des fins militaires le terrorisme
d'ailleurs avait déjà commencé cela mais
ça veut dire aussi que la réponse ne
sera pas que pour le budget des AR ou
pour les forces armées les attaques
cyber sur les hôpitaux que nous avons
connues ces dernières semaines montre
bien la complexité de cette affaire là
ça veut dire aussi qu'on a une
préparation de l'ensemble de la nation
le fameux mot résilience là pour le fou
pour le coup peut-être convoqué pour le
faire et je regarde le ministre délégué
en charge des Outre-mer certains
territoires de la République seront
sûrement plus vulnérables à l'hybridité
et assez vulnérabilités de par les
élongations la tyrannie des distances ou
la structure même des systèmes
d'information autant de sujets sur
lequel il nous faudra revenir et
monsieur le Président sur lequel nous
aurons besoin du Sénat puisque ces
sujets news obligent pour notre
génération mais aussi pour les
générations qui viendront merci beaucoup
merci monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues
je vous remercie
[Musique]
je remercie les membres du gouvernement
qui ont été présents ce soir sur le
ministre en charge du relation avec le
Parlement je vais lever la séance notre
prochain séance aura lieu le mercredi 2
novembre à 15h
pour les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement la séance est levée